a very strange anomaly sits in a
humanoid containment cell in the minimum
security wing of site 17 he walks talks
and looks like a man but everything else
is convoluted in a question mark this is
SCP 343 who like his Nam sake God is
likely to cause arguments whenever he's
brought up is he the creator of all that
exists the basis for the abrahamic
faiths or is he a pretender a reality
warper with immense power and dilection
towards delusion a courtesan of the
House of madog Matthew Methuselah Yahweh
who knows really it depends on who you
ask and which stories you choose to
believe and few people enjoy a good
story more than SCP 343 himself if one
day you take the time to visit him in
his room and ask him to reveal a page in
the long book of his personal history he
might be kind enough to tell you a story
a story like this of an encounter with
something monstrous that few others
could hope to survive meeting face to
face rewind a few thousand years nobody
knows how many exactly God as he chooses
to dub himself walked across the cracked
ground on worn sandals it'd been some
time since he'd seen an animal around
here and even longer since he'd seen a
human being not that this bothered him
he'd never been bothered by his own
company on a long walk like this of
course he could have sped up time or
teleported but where was the fun in that
he was a tourist in the world of
sensation of experience of Flesh bone
dirt blood and Sand after all where's
the fun in creating a whole universe if
you can't drop in now and then to visit
and do as the Romans do not that the
Romans would be around for another few
thousand years even Atlas must
occasionally shift the weight of the
globe from his shoulders for a ja around
the cosmic neighborhood and whatever
pass is for fresh air in the vacuum God
whistled a tune to himself it was a
craggy mountainous region he'd found
himself in the distant Peaks had Frosted
caps a breathtaking place where many
truly had their breaths taken away how
humans will so happily risk their lives
to do something extraordinary it never
ceased to amaze him his stomach rumbled
oh how he enjoyed that sensation one of
the funny little quirks of this human
form that he weaved for himself it was
no reason to be concerned if memory
served from his last trip through the
area a few decades before there was a
Friendly Village not far from here they
had always accepted him as a genal
stranger having no knowledge of his true
power God had always believed that a
person's goodness is defined by how they
treat those from whom they had nothing
to gain so it caused him great concern
as he approached the village and saw
great plumes of smoke Rising into the
sky he was so shocked by this that he
could decide to break his rule about
walking as a man in case there was still
some way he could help with a snap of
his fingers he disappeared and
reappeared in the center of The
Village's Town Square total devastation
huts and houses had been torn asunder
broken weapons lay on the ground some
places were on fire others smeared with
streaks of blood like some terrible
battle had occurred here but something
was wrong no bodies not one from
defender or or a salent How could a
thriving Village be so thoroughly
destroyed and not leave a single corpse
it was an act so bizarre and depraved
that it left even God puzzling that was
another downside of his human form here
on Earth he didn't have access to True
omniscience How could a mere human mind
Bound by the constraints of linear time
ever truly comprehend the total of
existence even attempting to do that
here would melt the brain of his human
body in it skull and leave a dribbling
out of his nose and ears instead he
chose to walk around the ruins of the
village and investigate first hand
arrows and broken Spears and swords
littered the ground some buildings were
demolished but there were no tracks or
stray projectiles that could suggest the
presence of Siege weapons now these
buildings looked like they were ripped
apart some even still had claw marks
what terrible Beast could have set upon
this town and done this then then he
heard a voice quiet and pleading beneath
some nearby rubble a Survivor he rushed
over to the pile and evaporated it with
a thought underneath a feeble old man
covered in stone dust was quivering God
helped him up and guided him into one of
the few remaining Huts still standing in
the village they both took seats God
held up two hands cradling empty space
two cups suddenly occupied that space
both filled with warm healing tea
he passed the old man one of the cups
while sipping from his own he asked the
old man if he'd seen what had happened
the old man told him know he hadn't seen
anything in decades he'd been rendered
blind in his youth little did either of
them know that very blindness was the
only reason he was the sole survivor of
the massacre the blind man told God that
one of The Village's Scouts had gone up
into the mountain with a small Hunting
Party the group was gone for days until
one of the members the youngest among
them returned weeping frostbitten and
covered in blood he said that his
friends had been killed by a beast in
the mountains something that almost
looked like a man but terribly wrong and
its face its awful awful face he would
never forget it he was just lucky to
escape with his life when the others
were torn apart but when the young man
returned he brought the shadow of death
with him it was a curse that doomed the
entire Village men women and children to
a terrible fate and that fate was upon
them a mere hour after the Survivor had
returned of course there were gaps in
The Blind Man's understanding given he
was lacking one of his major senses but
the sounds he could describe with
perfect clarity it was faint and distant
at first that awful whale and the
Galloping hands and feet thundering
against the ground faster than any horse
could move getting closer and closer
another villager saw it approaching and
screamed then it was upon them the
Villager screamed but it screamed louder
always wailing and shrieking and sobbing
like a monster crawling Straight Up From
Hell people tried to fight it by the
sounds of it the blind man with teary
blank eyes recalled the sounds of arrows
knocking and swords clashing against
something but even their greatest
warriors had screamed and died those who
saw it and tri tried to flee and hide
were slaughtered all the same soon
enough there were only two sounds left
in the village the monster and the blind
man both weeping he didn't understand
why it never took him it wasn't fair it
took everything else to leave him here
alive when everyone and everything he'd
ever known was destroyed was a greater
punishment than even death after killing
all of these Innocents the monster had
simply wandered off to the mountains
again the sound of its quiet sobs
getting smaller and smaller until it was
gone altogether God comforted the blind
man as he wept for the loss of all his
loved ones he told the blind man that he
would venture up to the mountains
himself and confront the creature on its
own territory and at the very least find
out why it had done this terrible thing
but first he must relocate the blind man
to a safer place he placed a hand on the
Blind Man's shoulder and he vanished he
would appear in an another Friendly
Village miles away God sent a silent
message into the minds of every villager
take good care of this man he has
undergone Horrors you can't even imagine
your kindness will be rewarded later for
that you have my promise God sighed and
turned his tired eyes to the distant
mountains a monster lurked up there
perhaps one of his own Creations or
maybe a Corruption of one of his
Creations either way whatever existed
without his knowledge existed without
his consent and he intended to know of
the beast in the mountains though given
what he'd seen already he didn't expect
to receive a warm welcome from this
murderous demon miles away up in the
mountains the creature licked the blood
from its cracked lips it looked like it
might have once been a human being or
something that aspired to humanity or
mocked it with its very existence it was
a huge gangling Beast East Skin
alablaster eyes empty and soulless
dribbling rivulets of burning tears down
a hideous gaunt face he crawled into the
Frozen mouth of a cave with great icicle
fangs wheezing and weeping all it ever
wanted was to be alone why did they have
to keep interfering didn't they know
what happened all the terrible things
they made it do the creature curled its
long gangly body into the fetal position
scratching great rots into the sides of
its bald Cranium with long sharp fingers
Terrible Things terrible terrible things
and then there was a brilliant flash
just a few feet away the monster was
surprised it turned to see a figure
silhouetted in the mouth of the cave he
wore sandals and thin robes his eyes
glowed with a kind of power that the
monster didn't recognize this stranger
stared at the monster without an ounce
of fear in his heart he stared right
into its eyes un wavering no no no no no
no he could feel it again the rage
bubbling up deep down a cauldron of
seething anger it hated the feeling like
being lowered into a vat of molten metal
unspeakable fire and pain coursing
through every vessel he began to weep
and scream while the stranger in the
cave mouth just watched not moving a
muscle do you know who I
am the stranger asked with a deep voice
that betrayed almost infinite power
knowledge and wisdom but it wouldn't
change the outcome here the monster
bounded at him at speeds that wouldn't
be seen again until jet planes and
bullet trains are invented Millennia
into the future its jaws were hanging
impossibly wide fangs borne its arms
extended and deadly claws ready to
strike but before those terrible hands
could close around the stranger he
vanished the monster stumbled and rolled
across the snow confused what trickery
was being used here I'll take that as a
not no said the voice from behind him
you ought to show your father some
respect more respect than you gave to
those poor people down in the village at
least seething the creature turned and
saw the stranger standing back in the
darkness of the cave staring at him but
the Beast didn't have the capacity for
awe or holy Terror only violence
boundless Limitless Unstoppable violence
it darted towards the stranger again
trying to strike him somehow it was like
fighting in an empty robe not a single
one of its deadly strikes seemed to hit
the stranger the stranger leap backwards
putting some space between himself and
the monster but still not breaking a
sweat he breathed in deeply then exhaled
the breath came out like a mighty
typhoon shocking even the monster with
its sudden force it was blown backwards
a leaf in the wind until its Long Claws
dug into the ground and anchored it in
place the stranger gave a r smile at
this impressed my my you're certainly a
tenacious one aren't you he said perhaps
we can talk for a little while instead
of fighting I want to know why you
killed all those people no answer the
Beast roared its Mighty limbs pounding
into the ground as it closed the gap
between itself and The Stranger in
fractions of a second it would kill him
rent him destroy him just like all the
others he'd left it no choice suddenly
the ground below it seemed to give way
the creature was confused it looked down
to see that the ancient stone Below had
somehow taken on the properties of a
liquid and it was sinking the Beast
panicked and it began to thrash it was a
strong swimmer but it didn't expect to
need to swim here the shock was too much
and soon the ground submerged it
entirely muffling its terrible Roars and
shrieks and just like that the ground
was solid again trapping the Beast
inside the stranger stepped forward and
looked at the ground a much needed time
out he said you do yourself no good
struggling like this despite its
terrible capacity for evil God couldn't
help but admire the beast at least on
the level of construction it was so
paired down so unburdened a killer to
the core but seemingly unkillable had he
made this creature bill ions of species
and the species those in turn had
created through billions of years of
breeding and evolution and somewhere
along the line this thing happened it
was easy even for the universe's Creator
to lose track of some of the tinier
variables and in the grand scheme of
things even this monster was still a
tiny variable but right here right now
it was still one hell of a problem the
ground rumbled below God cracks formed
the mountain peak shook God raised an
eyebrow genuinely impressed as the
monster ripped free of its Stone prison
and re-entered the fry it roared and
screamed still its blank eyes fixed on
him its skeletal body throbbed and
heaved with power unlike any other
creature in nature it was almost like
the longer their conflict went on the
more energized the Beast became God's
side all those poor villagers they never
stood a chance against this monster it
lunged for him him even faster and
stronger than before he teleported out
of the way in the nick of time and the
beast's claws cleav through a nearby
cave wall effortless God materialized
nearby but he didn't have time to speak
the Beast lunged again and again and
again every time he reappeared the Beast
went for him with impossible speed
deciding to widen the playing field God
teleported to the top of the mountain
the creature somehow sensing his
presence vaulted upwards and tunneled
through the roof Ro of the cave bursting
out of the ground in front of God who is
floating just slightly off the ground it
would be wise of you to stop God
carefully in toned all this time you
know I've been going easy on you you
don't want to find out what the wrath of
God looks like storm clouds were
gathering above Mighty Thunder roared
across the sky the Beast was undeterred
it roared and galloped towards God and
God in turn called down response a
volley of lightning the likes of which
the world has never seen before or since
struck down on the charging monster the
sudden white flash could Sting the eyes
from miles away the monster shrieked
from the blast feeling its flesh lift
off its bones and atomize in the sheer
heat of the electricity around it it
could smell itself cooking the lightning
blast only lasted for a few seconds but
for the Beast it felt like eternity when
the onslaught stopped the air was still
heavy with electrical potential
potential God stared down at the black
Scorch mark on the side of the mountain
where the creature had been standing all
the snow within a mile had been
evaporated by the blast it was a raw
display of the power of nature that
would make even Zeus tremble in his
sandals and yet there was still movement
something started to get up from the
burnt patch where nothing should be Left
Alive a blackened skeleton rising
shakily from the ash but still very much
alive as it started to Rise new flesh
began growing over its bones little by
little even God was astonished by the
sight of it he'd never seen a creature
cling so ardently to life in spite of
having truly unsurmountable power
amassed against it it was up against God
and still it fought the monster tottered
on its freakishly long limbs still
disoriented unusually staggered for a
creature driven by such single-minded
violent purpose when enough of its face
grew back to do so it began to weep and
SOB again tears streaking down its
terrible face looking at this creature
after all of this God couldn't help but
feel a new emotion pity he lowered
himself to the ground and approached the
creature like none had ever done before
he gathered it up into his arms and he
held it feeling its heaving wretched
sobbs against him the Beast was in so
much pain he could feel it radiating
from within speak my son God said in a
soft fatherly voice and for the first
and only time the monster spoke
can can
see make me out people no wonder people
can look can look
please that was all it managed to choke
out before devolving back into
unintelligible Babble but it was enough
enough for God to understand its pain he
did not know if it would be right to
change the monster's nature is it ever
right to truly change anyone's nature
but it was within his almost Limitless
power to Grant it one reprieve from pain
he settled the beast in the snow below
him it was quiet and still and God said
unto the Beast rest now child rest for
thousands of years if you must I hope
only that when you eventually awaken you
feel differently and so another story
from the catalog of SCP 343 of course it
leaves us with certain questions Chief
among them being is it true did 343 and
096 have this chance encountered long
ago or is this just another tall tale
from an anomaly who fancies himself a
deity we have our truth and you have
yours let us know what you believe Down
Below in the comments a month ago Dr
Robert Maxwell was a senior researcher
working at the facility but a tragic
mistake had cost the lives of several of
his
co-researchers now he was being led down
a bleak hallway in armed biocontainment
Area 14 a rifle wielding guard flanking
him on either side the once Rising
researcher had a very different title
now D
8724 he had been made a d-class
Personnel a death
sentence however as the guard led him to
his possible demise he wasn't dressed in
the typical d-class orange jumpsuit no
he was dressed in frilly rcoo dining
wear more typical of 18th century France
if anything Dr Maxwell looked like he
was on his way to meet royalty and in a
sense he was the former researcher had
begged for any other assignment but the
site director insisted on committing Dr
Maxwell to tea time with SCP
082 he'd always been the talk type so
the two would make a perfect pairing and
if the creature found him sufficiently
amusing then Maxwell might even leave
the containment cell alive he had heard
Legends of the giant creature they
called the cannibal Maxwell hoped they
were just stories Dr Maxwell was pushed
by the guards into a large luxuriously
appointed room and the doors were locked
behind him he felt like a child
surrounded by freakishly large furniture
and 10t high ceilings the fog of
obnoxious floral perfumes couldn't fully
cover up the pervasive smell of death
that lingered in the cavernous Halls of0
82's Palace thanks to an elaborate ruse
conducted by the foundation SCP 082
believed he was the King of France and
that his containment cell was a palace
where he remained for his own safety the
creatures continued good behavior and
everyone else's safety relied on
visitors keeping up that line Maxwell
had never worked in this area of the
facility so a lot of the standard
procedures were new to him still his
Superior had given him a clear directive
talk to the monster communicate with him
be cordial and friendly see if you can
find out more about his mysterious past
and most importantly if you want to
survive don't annoy him the down on this
Lu scientist gulped inside trying to
steady his nerves in this oversized fake
french Palace he just kept thinking
surely he can't be that big he almost
talked himself into believing that the
accounts of the creature were just that
tall tales until a huge figure began
lumbering into the main chamber it was
him SCP 082 also known as Fernand the
cannibal SCP 082 was an 8ft tall hulking
monster built sturdier than the castles
it likes to imagine are its true home
swollen bloated and grossly out of
proportion the creature clocks in at
over 700 lb
most of which is pure muscle that's
almost impossible to pierce with
conventional Weaponry SCP 082 stopped
just feet away and stared at Dr Maxwell
with its Beady sunken in eyes like a
hungry rat just the sight of it struck
Terror into Dr Maxwell's heart but he
didn't dare show his fear instead he
remembered his brief training bowing
politely and forcing a smile referring
to the creature as your highness and
profusely thanking it for granting him
an audience the monster continued
staring without saying anything and then
gave a wide lock jawed grin showing off
its huge teeth it did everything through
gritted teeth except eat and sing Dr
Maxwell hoped he wouldn't be a part of
either activity Fernand gave a low
booming chuckle he thanked Dr Maxwell
for coming to give him some company and
invited him to come further inside and
take a seat adding with a slight wink
that he won't fight the monster
complained that he so rarely gets
visitors to the Palace these days but he
omitted the fact that the main reason
for this was his tendency to devour them
Maxwell nodded and followed the giant
deeper into its oversized Abode he
couldn't help but noticed that the
monster's arms looked like huge fleshy
punching bags he knew that if ferand
wanted to he could easily crush him flat
just like he' done to so many
unfortunate guards during containment
breaches ferand told Dr Ma well that he
was thinking of having some decorating
work done the walls of his Palace were
starting to look awfully draa and he
gestured to one covered with a rusty red
streak Maxwell remembered that d-class
cleaners were sent into the containment
cell twice a month to tidy any of
ferdinand's messes but they often ended
up becoming one of the messes themselves
the creature encouraged Maxwell to take
a seat at his oversized dining table
while he tended to a pot of what he said
was full of delicious onion soup Maxwell
obliged his host's request and took a
seat at a huge chair that made him look
like a six-year-old sitting at the
grown-ups table meanwhile Ferdinand was
using a huge machete like knife to
cleave onions in half for his bubbling
pot of stew even though Ferdinand had
shown no signs of outward aggression as
he watched the cannibal hack away at
onions with his enormous knife Maxwell
could feel himself beginning to sweat
after all they didn't call this creature
the cannibal for nothing this was a
monster with a truly horrify ing body
count during previous containment
breaches it had taken enough
tranquilizer to put down two elephants
to subdue the creature but not before
multiple agents quite literally lost
their heads in the process ferin was
able to bite them off with one huge
Chomp like he was eating a drumstick
snapping right through the bone with his
incredible tooth and jaw strength
surprisingly when he wasn't on a violent
Rampage Foundation researchers had found
SCP 082 to be unusually polite and
forthcoming coming offering the
researchers plenty of information about
himself and his past the only problem
was that almost everything the creature
said was a complete lie from his time as
a researcher Maxwell knew that there
were only a few details about the
creature that could be ascertained for
certain SCP 082 would reliably answer to
the name Ferdinand and genetically
Ferdinand was technically human the
means by which Ferdinand became so
grotesquely huge strong and
cannibalistic are still unknown
Foundation Personnel are still looking
into whether it's due to some kind of
anomalous genetic mutation or by more
Supernatural means all we know is that
he's big unpredictable and extremely
dangerous Dr Robert Maxwell sat
terrified at the dining table of SCP 082
listening to fernand's slightly dull
blade chopped through the final onion
which he then tossed into the boiling
soup ferand had switched the topic of
conversation to one of his favorite
fictional characters Hannibal Lecter of
course Hannibal the cannibal isn't quite
so fictional to ferna while he's been
shown to be extremely intelligent in
terms of puzzle solving and memory he
seems to have no understanding of the
distinctions between fiction and reality
he assumes all movies and TV shows are a
form of documentary or reality
television and ever since seeing the
Silence of the lamps Ferdinand has been
eager to meet with Dr Lecter which he
emphasized to Maxwell over and over
since trying to explain the concept of
fiction to Ferdinand had never
previously worked Maxwell simply told
him that Dr Lector is extremely busy at
the moment but will visit whenever he
gets a chance this seemed to satisfy
ferand who plays two large bowls of
steaming soup on the table before
sitting down a little too close to
Maxwell he couldn't help but notice that
the giant cannibal was now sitting
within biting distance and as a lowly
d-class nobody would be rushing in to
save him if things went sou ferand began
ranting through his clenched teeth once
more occasionally stopping to consume a
hefty spoonful of onion soup Maxwell was
sure to do the same not wanting to seem
anything less than polite but soon the
tenor of ferdinand's rant began to shift
typically the monster spoke French or
heavily accented English now he was
affecting the accent of a Victorian
gentleman peppering a speech with t ho
and the game is a foot Maxwell was
confused at first but quickly realized
the game Ferdinand was playing it's well
known that ferand is a pathological liar
who likes to play numerous characters
changing his mannerisms and clothes
accordingly these personas have included
a vampire Big Bird Andre the Giant
Foundation researcher Dr brigh The
Incredible Hulk Alexander the Great
Captain Hook Dr Frankenstein and
Frankenstein's monster and of course in
this case the iconic fictional detective
Sherlock Holmes fearing for his life in
this strange situation Dr Maxwell did
the only thing he could play along as
ferand reeled off his homesan delusions
Maxwell began to play the role of Dr
John Watson asking follow-up questions
and complimenting ferdinand's impeccable
deductive reasoning and it seemed to be
working Ferdinand played along too
acting as though the two of them really
were Arthur Conan Doyle's crime fighting
Duo towards the end of their game Dr
Maxwell was even starting to enjoy it
amazed that his quick thinking was
actually keeping him safe but just then
the cannibal froze as if in a trance he
locked eyes with Dr Maxwell like a mad
dog that you can't tell if it's going to
bite you or not he saw the creatures
gargantuan teeth separating its huge
Jaws stretching open this could surely
only mean one thing Dr Maxwell winced
and prepared for death cursing that all
of his quick thinking had amounted to
nothing ferand leaned towards him his
gaping ma with its hot onion scented
breath just inches away from Maxwell and
then he began to sing the cannibal broke
into a rockus Victorian Pub song happy
and jovial in his moment of Terror Dr
Maxwell had forgotten that this was the
other reason SCP 082 opens his
nightmarish Jaws relief washed over him
as he knew he was safe at least for the
moment not long after Foundation guards
arrived and escorted him from the cell
leaving the delusional giant to his own
devices back in the so-called Palace the
former researcher had done it he had
bested Ferdinand the cannibal and
hopefully it would be the last time he'd
ever be face to face with that deranged
giant unfortunately for Dr Robert
Maxwell in a performance review later
that week one of his superiors remarked
that Ferdinand enjoyed his company and
he had done a great job such a good job
in fact that fer
insisted he have Dr Maxwell for dinner
or any other meal for that matter
sometime very soon SCP 1730 is one of
the biggest threats the foundation has
ever faced SCP 1730 does not exist it
was June 5th when the compound was first
discovered a large complex of structures
in rural Texas about 15 km Northwest of
the Mexican border located in Big Bend
Ranch state park it was easily the
biggest structure in the area but there
was no record of any such structure ever
being built a massive network of power
stations containment facilities and
research buildings SCP 1730 looked like
it had been abandoned for a long time
the exterior was degraded but the
building was still operating a power
generator had been running for an
indeterminate amount of time even as the
infrastructure degraded power flickered
through the site and fuel leaked
frequently but there was one detail that
attracted the attention of SCP brass SCP
1730 bore identifying markings linking
it to Foundation site 13 a research
facility that was marked for
construction near gnome Alaska but site
13 had never been built having been
abandoned in the planning stages so why
is it in the middle of Texas fully
constructed and long abandoned the
foundation needed to know more and they
needed their best to investigate it was
time to call in the game wardens Apollo
3 the mobile task force used to
investigate dangerous sites was brought
in and five Elite agents were breeded
and sent in Ross Houston Noah ohal and
vgo it didn't take long for them to
discover that something was very wrong
with the site of SCP 1730 the facility
was located in the middle of South Texas
but the local Flora surrounding it was
native to Nome Alaska something had
transported a building that shouldn't
exist to another place and time
Commander Ross ordered his men to enter
with Houston taking the lead they
discovered that the entry LED down a
long staircase they descended slowly
following a strange light that no one
could identify but had a sudden shock
when they discovered that the basement
of the staircase was missing the light
suddenly stopped and it became so dark
that it was impossible to see what lay
beyond the staircase upon probing the
inky black void at the base of the
staircase they determined it wasn't a
fog or Shadow it was a liquid and it was
Rising Ross ordered the men to pull back
but Houston was In Too Deep he couldn't
break free from the inky black liquid
the men pulled him away and got him free
but his legs were gone not ripped off
because there was no blood anywhere
smoothly cut off as if they were never
there and as they put Houston down he
stood up on Phantom legs he didn't feel
any pain but everyone could tell
something was very wrong with this place
and the messages they started seeing on
the wall made clear they weren't the
only ones who knew it what happened to
site 13 death here not my body bleed
there had been other people or things
inside SCP 1730 and they wanted anyone
who entered to know know that this was a
very dangerous place to be as they
Advanced down the hall back toward the
entrance they saw it looked like a
person in the distance but as they
approached it became clear it wasn't
another Explorer it was an old horribly
disfigured corpse seemingly attached to
the wall not by chains but fused to the
wall in unnatural ways at first the team
seemed unconcerned recognizing the
corpse as someone named Zachary
fortunately command back at the base
realized this as the effects of some
sort of Cognito Hazard a mental
infection in the base they uploaded a
filter to their helmets and the team
recoiled in horror at the sight in front
of them but the horrors were just
beginning they turned around to see a
shimmering humanoid entity in the
hallway behind them as it approached its
footsteps distorted the hallway around
it pulled ap3 Noah torted without
touching him and as the soldier was
pulled into its clutches his body
started to distort vgo was next being
grabbed by the arm by a long appendage
and his arm started to change color and
distort but the foundation sent Apollo
three and prepared Houston produced a
portable reality anchor designed to
handle reality warping entities and with
a flash of red light the creature was
revealed it was a horribly elongated
humanoid that only existed for a second
before the reality anchor erased it and
restored the hallway to its normal State
Vigo would recover with the strange red
color in his arm fading eventually Noah
wasn't so lucky he was already dead had
been fused into the wall just like the
unfortunate corpse these Horrors had
been encountered just by trying to
return to the entrance so it was clear
the only smart thing to do was to
descend further into the facilities and
get some answers as they Advanced not
encountering any other Supernatural
entities they saw more evidence of the
dark things that had occurred in site 13
the infirmary had been torn apart a
cafeteria had been melted into slag and
a large group of containment cells ended
with a section called Olympia class but
while most of the other cells were
standard sized these were over 100 m
High what had the foundation or whoever
ran this place been keeping in these
cells they would get more answers as
they made their way down the hall where
they saw a single television still
working and Illuminating the hallway at
first the television flickered but the
image soon cleared and the Agents were
able to see what it was broadcasting it
was the interior of a containment cell
and there was someone in it and they
recognized them as one of the most
dangerous beings contained by the SCP
Foundation Bobble the clown a predatory
Supernatural clown that inhabits a
children's TV show Bobble the clown was
broadcast by an unknown source and could
only be seen by children under 10
originally seeming to be a normal kid
show about a clown every episode
eventually devolved into the murderous
Bobble teaching kids how to do horrible
things like arson and torture the
foundation eventually captured and
isolated bobble's broadcast but the
clown remained hostile and vicious but
not here as the team talked to the
Bobble trapped in the mysterious sight
13 it became clear that this clown was
broken by whatever it had experienced it
rambled it hid from the camera and it
was clearly terrified as it told the
team about the horrors of the sight and
it seemed to recognized the agents as
something familiar but not completely
familiar it claimed to be able to smell
them and it said they smelled different
as Bobble rambled on the agents learned
about a man named Emerson who ran the
site like the foundation he was obsessed
with containing the strange and
dangerous entities in the world but
unlike the foundation he didn't just
want to protect the world from them he
hated them the entities in sight 13
didn't even have numbers Emerson wanted
to use them up however he wanted and to
dispose of them and something Bobble
called the meat grinder entities that
outlived their usefulness were taken
down below and none were ever heard from
again it was directly countered to every
SCP Foundation policy but this site had
clearly been performing these horrible
experiments for years how and why hadn't
anyone heard of it the team continued to
make their way into the facility but
their signals were lost as they entered
the cryogenics unit by the time
contacted been restored they were no
longer alone there were survivors both
agents of the foundation and survivors
of the facility and they were angry with
no way out and massively outnumbered
they called for backup mobile task force
T5 also known as samsara was reserved
for the heavy duty missions they're an
elite group of practically Immortal
cyborgs fashioned from the Flesh of a
God and equipped with further cybernetic
enhancements to eliminate keer Level
Threats and to protect themselves from
Cognito hazards they were sent in
through a drainage gate to look for
survivors and neutralize whatever lay
within they didn't know what to expect
but they knew one thing no one who had
been sent in had come out it wasn't long
before they realized how dangerous this
Mission would be as they came across
some large gated drainage pipes they
could see at least 20 charred bodies of
humanoids pushed up against the gate
some reaching their hands through
whatever it happened in sight 13 these
unfortunate beings had been desperate to
escape as they made their way down the
drainage pipe they could feel it getting
hotter as if they were nearing an energy
source there was one other odd thing
about the pipe it was draining inward
not out they made their way into a
control room where many of the consoles
had been destroyed looking through a
window their view was obscured by a
mysterious black mass on the control
panels they could read terms like
incinerator and body pit access they
split up trying to find answers but
found many of their accesses blocked by
the black mass as the T5 task force
argued over their next move they were
startled by a sudden jolt the Giant Mass
had started moving the team watched as
the mass spun revealing a giant turbine
which turned the inky substance into a
fine slurry That Was Then scorched by
giant streaks of fire one of the T5 shot
open the glass chamber allowing the team
to get closer and Blasting them with a
wave of heat as they descended into the
chamber they could see a massive
plant-like structure overhead which
started to shake suddenly thousands of
glowing pods were released from the
massive plant and each one lit up and
let the team view the chamber more
clearly but it was what was inside the
pods that was more disturbing each pod
had a humanoid shape inside seemingly
reaching toward the team until they hit
the slurry below and the Shadows went
dark the team descended to investigate
the slurry when something started to
leak out of the walls looking at it they
could see something moving within one of
the team members picked up the wriggling
object out of the black liquid and it
took a bite of his hand it was a leech
and there were thousands more of them
moving toward the slurry consuming it
and as the leeches ate they started
growing they see to be moving in unison
communicating with a larger being
lurking at the base of the slurry a
larger leech a queen or something else
the team wasn't sticking around to find
out they beat A hurried escape from the
leech room finding themselves in another
hallway whatever the black substance was
the entities who had been here had used
it scrawling Blood on the walls over and
over again occasionally they would come
across a drained corpse covered in the
black fluid had the leeches bled them
dry the facility was so sprawling that
the team knew if they wanted any chance
of navigating it safely they needed to
get the lay of the land they needed to
find the control center the door read
stairs to cryonics and the leeches were
nowhere to be found it seemed like a
safe path but as soon as the team
entered the temperature dropped
drastically to well below where it would
be safe for a human to survive the
team's internal heating system kicked in
to save their lives but it wasn't the
only threat the team was about to
encounter exactly what site 13 was
keeping locked up as soon as they
entered the room sound ceased to work
the filters in their gear overloaded and
the team saw warnings around the room
silence don't look a massive multi-m
figure emerged with each of its 60 arms
moving independently the creature had no
head but a large circular structure
covered with ancient glowing symbols
whatever it was it was ancient all
powerful and deadly the team scrambled
to get away as the glyphs on the
creature burned white hot anyone who
touched it was burned anyone who looked
too long at it felt their Optical
implants burn out the symbols on the
creature were indecipherable but one one
word was clear and printed in English
Emerson site 13 was from another world
another timeline where the SCP
Foundation evolved into something
horrible ruled over by Elliot Emerson it
tortured and captured its beings and
eventually killed most of them in the
horrors of the incinerators when an
escape threatened to destroy the
facility Emerson successfully activated
a device that removed the facility from
their world into hours of course as any
Avid follower of the SCP Foundation will
know there's far more to the story than
this Emerson may have been the start of
site 13's problems but he was far from
the end it's the mission of the century
a daring rescue into the depths of one
of the most dangerous locations in the
Multiverse site 13 otherwise known as
SCP 1730 when the impossible site 13 was
first discovered multiple mobile task
forces were sent to plummet depths and
none returned they were greeted to a
labyrinth and Nightmare littered with
deadly Cognito hazards escaped scps and
mysterious murderous leeches some were
trapped along with the civilians they
were were sent to rescue others were
killed or changed in unimaginable ways
mobile task force Apollo 3 also known as
the game wardens had been sent in on a
rescue mission when they encountered a
horrifying sight the captured broadcast
of Bobble the clown a dangerous SCP
known for corrupting and destroying
children through its deadly messages but
this Bobble was different much like
everything from site 13 this Bobble came
from an entirely different dimension and
he had terrifying information to relay
in the universe where site 13 originated
the site psychopath athic director one
Elliot Emerson had struck a deal with
the global occult Coalition a
controversial government group who
intends to protect Humanity by killing
anomalies rather than containing them
Emerson had converted his sight into an
unethical unrestrained slaughterhouse
and was incinerating scps by the hund in
a so-called body pit but Emerson's Game
of Death came back and bit him snapping
the threads of reality and turning the
entire site into a dimensionally
displaced super anomaly the game wardens
realized they were in way way over their
heads their chances of surviving this
place were dropping by the second and if
they wanted any chance of succeeding in
their mission they needed backup so
sight command called in MTF to 5 AKA
samsara calling in samsara for a
run-of-the-mill collection mission is
like using a bazooka to kill a housefly
but for a case as sever 1730 their
skills were not only nice to have but
vital samsara are among the best of the
best Immortal cybernetic clones forged
from the Flesh of a god equipped with
weaponry and technology that could
surpass even that of other Elite Mobile
task force units the four members of
samsara are so Adept at what they do
they earned the nickname Power Rangers
among their peers the remaining game
wardens knew that with samsar on the
case they may actually survive this
thing after all and they just needed to
hold out samsara arrived on site not
long after packing some serious
technological heat including arm-mounted
incendiary cannons shock absorbing leg
extensions heat resistant plating and
built-in scramble adaptations within
their eyes to ward off the deadly
Cognito hazards everyone involved was in
for the fight of their lives the four
samsara agents iranu nanu munu and onu
entered via a drainage gate in one of
The Office Buildings above ground and
began their descent inside after
observing numerous charred bodies they
deduced that there must have been a
massive incinerator somewhere on site
Emerson's incinerator theorizing that
this was connected to the body pit they
kept hearing about they descended
further feeling the temperature rise as
they did so due to the anomalous nature
of 1730 nothing inside made any kind of
logical sense caused by a reality
warping machine known as thresher the
internal geography of site 13 was
subject to constant shifts the team then
split up to cover more ground Monroe and
nanu continued to follow the pipes and
the heat toward the furnace while iranu
and onu broke away to explore what lay
Beyond a weak wall after busting through
the wall iranu and onu explored several
empty office blocks before finding their
way into a control room with a glass
observation deck while the window was
obscured by garbage and human corpses
signage indicated that the incinerator
and the body pit were directly below
them the team once again reconvened and
managed to activate the incinerator
which shredded the mass stuck inside
with several large turbines before
burning the resulting slurry the same
process that had happened to so many
anomalies under Emerson's watch with the
path cleared samsara decided to descend
via the incinerator using the drainage
pipe as a kind of makeshift tunnel
eventually they happened upon the
leeches large black and hungry these
creatures seemed to infest 1730 by the
Thousand anywhere that blood or drainage
runoff could be found the leeches could
be found too they didn't appear to have
any connection to an anomaly previously
secured and contained by the foundation
they squeezed and wriggled through the
cracks in the walls searching for fresh
blood on R detected that the leeches all
moved with a kind of collective purpose
suggesting a telepathic Hive mine onu
was able to tap into this Hive M using
her cybernetic enhancements and map the
chaotic geography of 1730 through the
leech colony's Collective knowledge with
this new Advantage they could add a
second goal to this Rescue Mission find
the thresher device causing all the
instability and potentially reduced
power to it if possible but they were on
the clock to save the other survivors as
those leeches were sure to get hungry
for warm blood soon they followed the
leeches down the most direct path toward
the survivors on the way they
encountered a horrifying creature the
many limed humanoid nightmare that
functions as Emerson's Eternal
punishment his charred body tied
screaming and alive to the platform
where the monster's head should be they
managed to make it past the monster
before finally rending with captain
hollus of mobile task force 8 and9
otherwise known as the mole rats as well
as the game wardens and the other
survivors there were 27 surviving
members of site 13 staff many of which
had severe injuries making it even
harder to transport them back to safety
through the Hazardous terrain and to
make matters worse the leeches were back
the team quickly decided that the best
route out of here was directly past the
thresher where they could reduce power
to the machine for just long enough to
create a stable path of Escape nanu
opened fire on a hord of approaching
leeches with a flame throw it and
everyone began running for their lives
it was a final make or break Dash to
safety however their Advance was soon
stopped by a strange red creature
drawing a kognito hazardous meme on the
wall with its claws when the team
attempted to engage it attacked exposing
additional deadly memes and the
dangerous effects of its single white
eye and we're not talking about internet
memes here these are simples and
information that are often deadly to
even bear witness to and for you or I
this would be a real threat but not to a
team equipped with goggles containing
cognitohazard filter technology the
battle was cut short when the floor
collapsed underneath them and the
creature was devoured by something even
larger and more monstrous a gigantic
black leech covered in huge red eyes its
entrance caused thousands of leeches to
spill out into the Hall as the monster
screeched and slithered its tentacles
after them allow us to introduce you to
Elijah also also known as the leech boy
and a pivotal component of the very
existence of SCP 1730 he was a boy with
the mind of a toddler but he had the
strange ability to absorb blood through
people's skin hence his nickname leech
boy one of the doctors in sight 13 Dr
Hadley took pity on Elijah after all he
didn't choose to be the way he was
director Emerson didn't share Hadley's
sympathy his orders to exterminate all
anomalies included humanoids like Elijah
when Hadley protested Emerson had her
beaten within an inch of her life while
other centers were shot Dr Hatley
disgusted by the inhumanity of her
superiors devised the perfect Revenge
she sabotaged the incinerator and the
body pit allowing a mass containment
bridge that flooded the site with deadly
anomalies young Elijah ended up
consuming the slurry of the other
shredded anomalies causing him to mutate
into a powerful monster a behemoth of a
leech who gave birth to and controlled
all the others it was hatley's Revenge
that caused Emerson to panic and
activate thresher leading to a rift in
reality in the creation of 1730 and by
extension all the problems faced by Our
Heroes today samsara and the others fled
leech boy and began taking a different
Escape Route however while on Route they
encountered the dreaded Crystal
butterflies a dangerous SCP capable of
destroying organic matter with a mere
touch iranu stepped up to bat roasting
the creatures with his arm-mounted
incinerator and taking extreme damage to
his body in the process but they didn't
have time to rest with the butterflies
disposed of they kept moving heading
toward the thresher but not all the scps
were necessarily working against them
Bobble the clown came in handy at the
next checkpoint manifesting in the
monitor of an electronic door and
opening the way through as they
continued on their Journey they had to
fight off frequent attacks from leeches
losing some of the task force members in
the process they were also forced to
face off against a number of other
anomalies in order to survive such as
SCP 2316 manifesting his floating bodies
beneath them and SCP 1370 which used a
huge mechanized body to attack the team
of survivors that was all just a warm up
for the true through final battle though
the floor shattered beneath them and out
of an impossibly huge chamber the
monster that had once been Elijah
wriggled free reaching for them with
huge tentacles and shrieking from its
thousand tooed ma it was at least 200 M
tall and barely reacted to any amount of
Firepower it seemed like they were all
doomed until Captain Hollis had a truly
crazy idea with the help of samsara she
led the bloodthirsty Abomination down
through the cryic center and into an
Olympia class testing chamber there as
the leech boy was bearing down on them
hollus opened the gates to two adjacent
containment cells and something Beyond
incredible happened two of the most
powerful scps ever known a giant sword
wielding gate guardian and the reality
bending Cosmic deer SCP 2845 entered the
arena What followed was one of the most
epic showdowns in the history of the SCP
Foundation As the deer and the gate
Guardian went to battle against the all
devouring leech while the monsters
fought Hollis ordered her team to get
the rest of the survivors to safety she
and moonu of the simp Sara team remained
behind to prevent any of the anomalies
from escaping as the entire base began
sinking into the ground from the
combined forces of the battle raging
around them and the thresher continued
Onslaught on reality even if the
survivors escaped with the anomalous
developments inside sight 13 escape and
wreck havoc on the World At Large that's
when Hollis received a vision a horrific
charred post-apocalyptic World roamed by
inconceivably powerful entities and
Nightmare Gods it was a vision so
horrific that just seeing it nearly
broke her mind she knew what she had to
do the only way she could truly defeat
this terrible place and ensure safety
for mankind while leech boy the gate
guardian and the deer continued their
battle for the ages Hollis ran to
thresher and forced the machine into
overdrive up above the remaining members
of ssara the mole rats and the game
wardens escorted the survivors to safety
downstairs thresher emitted a blinding
white light as the system began overload
in her final moments all Hollis could do
was laugh perhaps it was a laugh of pure
insanity of a mind broken by the horror
she witnessed or perhaps it was a laugh
of Victory knowing that in spite of the
immense Powers all around her she had
won the day she had saved not only the
survivors and her teammates but possibly
all of humanity and all it cost her was
everything outside the survivors had
reached a safe distance away when the
entirety of site 13 imploded in a final
brilliant flash when the dust cleared
SCP 1730 was gone all that was left was
an immense Crater where the impossible
base should have once been Captain
Hollis had done it through overloading
the thresher machine she'd taken this
anomaly out of the world the exact same
way it had entered it was torn from its
Moorings on our Earth and kicked in the
Infinity of SpaceTime perhaps never to
be seen again along with everything it
contained SCP 1730 was reclassified to
neutralized of course the foundation
would have plenty of other anomalies to
pursue soon after but the nightmare of
Emerson sight 13 was over once and for
all a light shines above a metal table
with the chair positioned on either side
this is the isolated hermetically sealed
interview chamber of provisional site 23
outside the room Waits two shellshocked
human mobile task force members another
with invisible ghost legs three powerful
cyborgs and a scientist From Another
Dimension they're all here to talk about
one thing the nightmare that unfolded at
site 13 also known as SCP 1730 everyone
thinks they know the story a mysterious
site suddenly appears in Texas seeming
to exactly match the blueprint for an
abandoned site that's supposed to be in
gome Alaska what started as a simple
anomalous location turned out to be an
epic horror From Another Dimension the
task forces sent in by the foundation
were either massacred or trapped inside
and those who survived reported seeing
unspeakable Carnage inside the base
including a death machine designed to
destroy anomalies and that's not all as
a result of the mysterious thresher
machine the entire location had been
transformed into a shifting spatial
anomaly filled with creatures straight
out of a nightmare from giant telepathic
leech monsters to huge multi-m demigods
that would eternally punish the site's
murderous director Elliot Emerson it was
only through the combined might of three
different mobile task forces including
the legendary samsara and the sacrifice
of Brave Captain Hollis that the cursed
location was finally flung into a
different dimension neutralizing the
threat it posed to our reality but for
the SCP Foundation the story doesn't end
with neutralization there's still plenty
more questions that need an and that's
why today we're going to tell you what
they found out after the neutralization
of SCP 1730 not only will we discover
what's become of the many people
involved we'll learn about what happened
in the last moments before the
neutralization took place and perhaps
most importantly of all for the sake of
our universe we'll find out how site 13
came into existence and how site
director Emerson went down such a dark
path it's time to get some answers
welcome to the final part of the SCP
1730 Saga as we close the book on one of
the most deadly locations in the
foundation Multiverse first to sit down
in the interview chair was Captain efim
Ross leader of the mobile task force
Apollo 3 also known as the game wardens
he was a shaken man looking far older
than his 35 years his eyes heavy with
the weight of the horrors he'd seen and
he and his team were among the first to
venture into the bowels of site 13 and
witnessed the atrocities that had gone
down there like the body pit full of
fleshy slurry or the countless
containment chambers that marked their
occupants for Viv section and
termination Captain Ross was haunted by
the things that happened to his team
under his watch as the anomalous
transformation of Houston's legs and the
nightmarish warping death of Noah at the
hands of a stretchy reality bending
anomaly he compared the state of chaos
going on down there to something like
Jurassic Park where all hell had broken
loose and the Monsters ruled he also
remarked on the Olympia containment
cells each the size of a football
stadium capable of containing things far
beyond the scope of this universe's SCP
Foundation his interviewer was the
hard-nosed Dr Peter Vincent who thanked
Captain Ross for his contributions and
called in the next interview subject
agent Liam moalo a game warden's Task
Force member working under Captain Ross
he had a thousand yard stare and even
the untrained Observer could see that
agent AAL had left some parts of himself
back in sight 13 when Dr venson
attempted to interview him he mostly
remained silent only volunteering one
Grim statement we should have died in
there this isn't real this isn't real we
were supposed to die in there next to be
interviewed was Captain iranu of mobile
task force to 5 AKA samsara his
interviewer Dr Isa stclair questioned
him about the nature of the mission and
the cybernetic Soldier was even keeled
about the matter he said that in spite
of regrettable losses of life he was
still satisfied with the outcome of the
mission overall the high value targets
were rescued the anomaly was for all
intents and purposes neutralized and the
degree of loss was actually better than
their premission predictions it seems
that the weight of death doesn't weigh
quite as heavily on those who will
probably never have to experience it as
the samsara team were capable of Simply
being rebooted into new bodies if
terminated in the field people like
Captain Hollis weren't as lucky next
agent cter Houston of the game wardens
was both interviewed and medically
evaluated by Dr Ian Harris agent Houston
had his legs dematerialized after he
tripped into a rising tide of anomalous
liquid which he described as looking
like a moving physical computer glitch
however in spite of this agent Houston
is still able to stand and move of his
own free will it seemed to Dr Harris
that Houston's legs Were Somehow trapped
between Dimensions Houston told Dr
Harris that he didn't experience any
kind of pain when his legs were removed
but to this day he occasionally feels
something furry brushing up against them
perhaps wherever his legs are they
aren't alone next the stoic agent moonu
of samsara was interviewed by Captain
Elliot O'Neal of mobile task force d26
also known as time cops Captain O'Neal
had a bone to pick with moonu namely
that he'd allow Captain Hollis to run
off and sacrifice her own life despite
having a clear directive to prevent the
human Task Force member members from
endangering themselves at any cost moonu
deflected claiming that when Hollis
separated from the group he assumed that
she ran off with intentions that never
included her own demise O'Neal and the
foundation found this answer
unsatisfying and decided to move on to
their next interview with onu the last
person with Captain Hollis before her
death the interviewer Dr Darien Arnold
probed the elite samsar operative on why
she turned off her camera before she and
Hollis reached the thresher the machine
that Hollis overloaded to annihilate
sight 13 from our Dimension she gave him
more compelling answer than Munro when
she and Hollis entered the server room
on the way to the thresher they
encountered what might have been the
ultimate Cognito Hazard it was a vision
of a terrifying alternate Dimension with
billions dead a poisoned star like the
biblical wormwood fell from the burning
Sky a nightmare God like the one
torturing Elliot Emerson wandered along
the fields of crucified people covered
in deadly Cognito hazardous ruins just
looking at it burned this scramble
technology out of moon ru's eyes and she
quickly turned off her cameras to avoid
potentially frying the the brains of
Mission Control Hollis wasn't so lucky
the things she witnessed broke her
sanity and when she finally overloaded
the thresher machine she was laughing
and crying finally and perhaps the most
enlightening debriefing interview of
them all site director William vestland
interviewed Dr Muhammad Scott the
highest ranking researcher of site 13
and Confidant of the now Infamous
director Elliot Emerson the question was
simple just what it happened for site 13
to become so messed up and Dr Scott
answered in detail with a tale of
corruption alternate realities and The
Perils of unchecked power in his home
Dimension site 13 was originally created
in Nome Alaska to house the corpse of a
giant sea creature that beached itself
on the border of India and Bangladesh in
1964 it became the largest and most
secretive Foundation containment
facility in the latter half of the 20th
century however disaster struck in 1994
when a Marxist extremist used an anomaly
to level the Willis Tower in Chicago as
a result the foundation lost a lot of
its funding and international support
leaving it dire Financial Straits enter
the True Villain of the site 13 story
Paul manfor if that name sounds familiar
to you it's because he was an associate
of President Trump in our universe who
got into legal trouble for shady
International dealings however in Dr
Scott's Universe he was a powerful
staffer for president Bob Dole who in
that reality had beaten Bill Clinton in
the 1996 presidential election manfor
was made the new Secretary General of
the global occult Coalition the un's
answer to the SCP Foundation and one of
the their leading competitors with an
ethos geared toward killing rather than
containing anomalies manfor and the go
co-opted the struggling Foundation
providing them with money in exchange
for control the foundation had no choice
but to accept the deal with the devil
slowly manfor replaced the foundation
Old Guard with Toadies and Loyalists the
Ethics Committee and the 05 command were
dismantled denters were dragged out of
their offices and shot point blank in
the head execution style site 13 had
originally been directed by Dr brigh but
brigh was arrested in contained under
false pretenses so manfor could install
a new director a mid-level researcher by
the name of Elliot Emerson Emerson is
often painted as a sadistic monster who
took pleasure in torturing anomalies to
death and flushing them down the body
pit the reality is both simpler and more
Grim Emerson it turns out was just an
eager yes man he was put into his
position to follow maniff for's orders
to a T and those orders were simple kill
in a perfect example of the banality of
evil Dr Emerson converted site 13 in
into a brutal slaughterhouse just as his
overlords at the GOC had ordered him but
things were quickly getting out of hand
and one of the most vocal critics of the
new regime was one of Emerson's old
lovers one Dr Vera Hadley assistant
director of anomalous biology Dr Hadley
was disgusted by the inhuman acts
Emerson was carrying out and couldn't
stay silent and for this she faced
horrific consequences corrupt guards
stripped her and beat her to within an
inch of her life in front of her
co-workers in that moment she swore her
revenge she sabotaged the containment
procedures and had the engineers rig the
already unstable thresher device to
overload as Emerson watched the
anomalies break containment he began to
fear for his life both from the
anomalies themselves and from the
punishments of his superiors at the GOC
Dr Scott revealed that Emerson was no
evil mastermind he was a lap dog for the
GOC a dirty coward all the way to the
very end and he was desperate he held Dr
Scott at gunpoint and ordered him to
activate the thresher or die and the
rest is history there would be no
Redemption for Dr Scott's former friend
as Emerson ended up chained to the Run
covered platform head of a nightmare God
for all eternity so ends the debriefing
of the site 13 survivors and closes the
book on that terrible place for now
anyway the story of SCP 1730 is anything
but simple and there are so many angles
from which this dark tragedy of Cruelty
and Corruption can be approached and
ultimately it was all for the same two
things at the root of every evil the
desire for money and power but the
pursuit of these base desires Canad lead
to some truly nightmarish consequences
and nobody knows this better than former
director Elliot Emerson who will be
paying for these sins until the end of
time and perhaps even beyond the desert
is still the night seems endless silent
and at peace until it's pierced by the
sound of gunshots and
screams deep in the Sahara the SCP
Foundation is Waging War against a newly
discovered enemy a squad of foundation
agents is retreating trying to get away
from the ones who massacred their allies
they were attempting to eliminate the
threat using conventional means but
their rifles were no match for the
reality bending entities of the kingdom
of abidon the retreating agents cover
one another as they make their way back
to the extraction point the enemy Force
advances agents that are caught too
close to the Sorcerers of abdon
disintegrate Into Thin Air this is not
an enemy they can defeat the SCP agents
need to get back to base and relay what
they have found to their
superiors out of the hundreds of Agents
sent into the Sahara that night only a
handful make it out alive they are
debriefed by their superiors at the
foundation who classified the anomalous
humanoids under the highest of threat
levels the kingdom of abdon is a threat
the kingdom of abdon must be eliminated
reconnaissance done prior to the
disastrous Mission had alerted the
foundation to the presence of anomalies
in the region but they had no idea how
strong the anomalous humanoids would be
from data gathered through old reports
it seemed like the abdon humanoids were
responsible for the deaths of no fewer
than 75 Foundation personnel and had
stolen at least 12 different items from
the foundation the leaders of the SCP
Foundation tasked research team Omega 5
with developing a weapon that would be
capable of destroying the kingdom of
abdon once and for all the weapon they
are researching must be capable of long
range destruction because the moment any
foundation agent gets close to the area
they are vaporized by the reality
manipulating powers of its inhabitants
the project is given the name twins of
God and is led by a foundation doctor
known only by the designation
051 051 is popular in the SCP Foundation
well known for his in-depth research in
charismatic personality making him the
perfect person to lead such a project
and 051 recently came across an anomaly
that he believes holds the solution the
foundation has been looking for to
defeat the kingdom of abdon item 01
and so the Omega 5 team gets to work
they discover that the anomaly has
incredible Powers when put inside a host
which they refer to as an item o1 entity
and set up a series of experiments using
different people to harness its energy
the first series of tests all end in
tragedy the anomaly causes the entity it
inhabits to become intensely radioactive
anyone who gets close to it succumbs to
immediate radiation sickness and
eventually death to stop the radiation
problems the Omega 5 research group
intensifies the containment procedures
051 receives reports from the high-ups
that the kingdom of abdon has attacked
another Foundation facility in Sudan
long range defense is needed ASAP the
administrator puts more pressure on
Omega 5 and especially its leader 051 to
solve the problems of item 01 and
develop a weapon that can save the
foundation he stays awake for days on
end working tirelessly to create a safe
and controllable item 001 entity
although there are signs that the weapon
will work it is still unpredictable when
item 001 is initiated the host entity
becomes paralyzed suffer severe cerebral
hren and soon a new host is needed
before testing Can Begin Again and
that's not the only thing that goes
wrong whenever the anomaly is put into a
new host sudden and random destruction
of on-site structures and Personnel take
place 051 knows though that if this
power can be harnessed and controlled in
the right way that it could be the
weapon that the foundation needs to wipe
out the kingdom of abidon once and for
all in order to control item o1 051 has
a mind kill switch implanted in its
host's brains 051 can activate the
implant to incapacitate its host and
immediately Stop The Unwanted
destruction countless hosts are
terminated by this mind kill switch in
the early trials conducted by the Omega
5 team but progress continues to be made
and eventually a hypothesis is
formulated perhaps the disastrous side
effects of item o1 can be offset by
spreading the anomaly across multiple
subjects they theorize that the immense
mental load of the anomaly can be
distributed among several hosts thus
reducing the toil it takes on each and
giving them the ability to control its
immense power but 051 and the Omega 5
team need more data and for that they
need more bodies they consult with the
director of site 17 and it is concluded
that the nearby town of San Marco would
be an appropriate place to get the
additional test subjects they require on
a quiet Sunday morning Omega 5 along
with support from a squad of armed SCP
agents Storm Into the San Marcos de la
sterna Church during the middle of mass
they gather up a number of the younger
congregants and bring them back to the
site where item 01 is housed the
researchers quickly ran through their
new supply of test subjects though and
Omega 5 would need to get even more if
their research was to continue instead
of going back and forth between the
testing facility and San Marcos 05 1
decided to move the entire item o1
operation to the town itself he renames
the town testing site o1 and Omega 5
rounds up 23 of the healthiest subjects
they can find for use in the next series
of research tests a few weeks after
occupying the town of San Marco Omega 5
makes its most substantial progress yet
just as they theorized by spreading out
the anomaly of item o1 across a specific
group of hosts they can control its
powers the test may have cost the lives
of almost everyone in the town but the
ends certainly justify the means the
kingdom of abdon poses an existential
threat to the SCP Foundation after all
and thanks to This research they will
soon have a weapon capable of bringing
them Victory the foundation administer
criticize 0 51's methods but can't argue
with his results unfortunately 051 has a
dark secret a secret that disturbs even
the most hardened and loyal members of
Omega 5 a secret that has to do with the
item 01 hosts the host that Omega 5 has
made its major progress with are not the
ordinary test subjects normally used by
the foundation no the test subjects 051
makes his breakthrough with are children
nine of them to be exact all between 4
and 11 years old despite being told
specifically by the foundation
administrator to only test on adults the
research required 051 to break the chain
of command and follow the science down
the path it led the children are
contained in a reinforced bunker where
only 051 and a select few have access
they are technically alive but are
functionally brain dead the group of
nine children share a hive mine that can
process information and more importantly
can unleash the full potential of the
implanted anomaly creating and
controlling a devastating power but not
everyone is thrilled with what they've
achieved members of Omega 5 are haunted
by the screams of the children that they
forced to be part of their weapons
development program they describe their
merging with item o1 as being a process
that rips out their souls and replaces
them with something much more Sinister
in fact all of Omega 5 regret what they
have been a part of and what they've
done all except 051 the nine children
can Channel unprecedented amounts of
energy from an unknown origin that Omega
5 hypothesizes comes from an
extradimensional source which is then
then used to unbind atoms at the quantum
level when the right activation words
are spoken it appears as though this
tremendous power gives the children the
ability to annihilate anything in the
entire universe it's a gun to end all
guns and only 051 has the key to control
it the nine children work so well with
an item o1 that Omega 5 reclassifies it
to include the nine children themselves
they are not just the entity housing or
controlling item o 1 they permanently
become item
o1 once Omega 5 has a better
understanding of item o1 they begin to
run tests to find out the full extent of
its abilities first they test the
distance item o1 can reach the initial
test that Omega 5 carries out is on a
steel rod placed 5 km away 051 orders
the children to destroy the target
moments later the phone next to 051
begins to ring when he picks it up the
Observer task with watching the pole is
on the other end end he informs 051 that
the steel rod has been completely
vaporized 051 is not satisfied though he
has another pole sent out this time
placed 8,000 km away from the nine
children 051 asked the children to
destroy that Rod almost immediately the
phone rings again the target has been
vaporized 051 Smiles the next series of
test Omega 5 runs on item 01 are to
determine the maximum size of an object
that can be destroyed the test start out
with a steel sphere 3 m in diameter
placed 1,000 km from item 01 051 orders
the children to destroy the object it is
instantly vaporized 051 has seen enough
small tests it's time for something big
so he does something that will later be
questioned by everyone at the SCP
Foundation he orders the nine children
to destroy a church of the broken God
worship site in Turkey not long after
the destruction order is given to item
01 reports begin coming in the worship
site has been obliterated with no
observable damage to the surrounding
area deadly and precise 051 closes his
eyes and takes a deep breath he looks as
if he's overcome by an immense spiritual
experience he opens his eyes leans over
to the children and Whispers the name of
someone later that day 051 finds out
that the target he had named has been
vaporized the success of Omega 5 in item
001 is relayed to the administration of
the foundation they are so impressed
that they make plans to use item 001 to
eliminate the abidon threat once and for
all however one of the heads of the
foundation administrator Williams has
major concerns about the way 051 is
running the program the updates that 051
has been sending have become less
scientific and more
philosophical
more spiritual administrator Williams
sends a letter to 051 reassuring him
that that he is doing good work but once
the mission to destroy the kingdom of
abdon is completed 051 will be promoted
to director and reassigned to the newly
constructed site 19 for the good of the
foundation and maybe the rest of the
world he'll be permanently moved away
from item
001 0 51's response is short and to the
point I am fine administrator the
project is finished we will complete our
task when you arrive administrator
Williams arrives at site 001 a few days
later he is greeted by 051 and the Omega
5 team Williams can't help but notice
that 051 has a strange look in his eyes
it is the look of a crazy man who has
been lost in his work and who has
perhaps lost himself Williams puts the
thought away though and walks with 051
and his accompanying agents to the
viewing area where the powers of item
001 will be
demonstrated administrator Williams and
the other agents will watch from a
protected viewing room as 051 enters the
Chamber of his new super weapon it's
time to see if their weapon that has had
so much time effort sweat tears and
especially blood poured into it will
have been worth it everyone watches as
051 leans over and says the name of the
abdon Citadel to the nine children all
at once they start to Glow no one
observing can see what is happened in
the far off Kingdom but they know
something big has happened the
administrators is thrilled but notices
something 051 hesitated a moment while
leaning over the children before
standing back up did he whisper
something else to them and then
administrator Williams vaporizes pulled
apart at an atomic level before he has
the chance to scream what's going on the
agents standing next to where
administrator Williams previously
existed begin to yell and pull out their
guns they burst through the door of the
observation room and run down the
hallway towards where 051 and the nine
children are located the arm agents rush
into the room but 051 is gone the nine
children are still over the next few
weeks 051 is reported to be seen several
times by SCP agents however no one is
able to catch him and it appears as
though other members of the SCP
Foundation have also gone awall as well
perhaps joining him on the run it is
unclear what his plan is but the reports
from the reconnaissance team sent into
the Sahara make it obvious what the
result of his first command to the
children was there isn't a single
humanoid or building left in the Kingdom
of abdon but even with this Victory the
highest levels of the SCP Foundation
have an ominous thought lurking in the
back of their minds where did 051 go and
what is he planning to do next following
the improper use of item o1 leading to
the untimely death of a high ranking
Foundation staff member the weapon was
deemed too dangerous and containment
procedures were implemented due to the
high amount of radiation they were found
to emit the nine children were placed
into lead line bags and buried under 50
m of concrete beneath the Church of St
Marcos de La Via
Eterna though all the children continued
to be functionally brain dead they still
display Signs of Life despite their
containment and by order of the overseer
Council have been classified as a Thal
entity it's a natural instinct in many
species to protect their young and
sometimes it's not just their own babies
but any young that look like them
regardless of your personal feelings on
hum earliest stage it is a scientific
fact that human babies are designed to
emphasize their own adorable
helplessness to make sure that other
older humans take care of them a baby's
cry is an inherently distressing sound
and when we hear it some deep Primal
part of us feels the urge to comfort and
care for the child until the sound stops
but of course we're talking about the
world of the SCP Foundation here where
there are bunnies that can eat anything
Teddy bears that might steal your organs
to make duplicates of themselves and
chocolate fountains filled with
trillions of murderous insects Nothing
Is What It Seems here and even the most
innocent and cute creatures may be
hiding A Deadly Secret SCP 734 being no
exception today we're talking about the
baby this anomaly proves that dangerous
things can come in small packages but
where others only saw misery and death
the SCP Foundation saw a certain
potential Our Story begins in the
maternity ward of a hospital in the USA
where every medical professional's worst
nightmare was unfolding an unknown but
incredibly fast acting flesh eating
pathogens seemed to be running rampant
across the hospital's population it
began when patients who weren't even
admitted for Dermatological issues
started complaining of severe itches and
extreme skin pain some nurses and
doctors in the Maternity Ward began to
experience similar symptoms as well as
one of the infants leading to a massive
quarantine effort while the initial
symptoms first appeared to be limited to
severe pain and discomfort on isolated
parts of the skin the condition of The
Afflicted soon escalated their skin
began to messily flake off as the cells
comprising it lost physical cohesion and
died it was a kind of strange anomalous
rot that seemed to work inwards first
destroying the Integrity of the outer
layer of skin and then cause f further
disintegration to deeper parts of the
body once the skin had shut off the
pathogen would turn its attention to
what was lying beneath Against All Odds
the disease affected organs muscle
tissue the vascular system and even
bones nothing was spared the victim's
bodies would completely break down and
they would be dead within a few hours by
the time the pathogen had finished
ravaging its victims what was left
didn't even look human anymore not only
patients but doctors and nurses that had
been walking the wards mere hours before
were now little more than piles of human
tissue sitting in what had previously
been their hospital beds whatever this
was it seemed like the fastest
progressing infection in recorded
history Hospital staff and
administrators were terrified this
appeared to be an entirely new disease
with a mysterious form of transmission
and worst of all no cure they were even
more confused news when several black
vans pulled up outside the hospital and
mysterious men in hazmat suits Spilled
Out and began setting up a quarantine
Zone around the entire building whoever
these strange people were they
definitely weren't the CDC little did
the hospital Personnel know that this
was the group you'd never want showing
up and putting your location on lockdown
it was the SCP Foundation the infected
remains of the victims were taken away
for research purposes and the foundation
operatives immediately began conducting
debriefing interviews with Witnesses
they soon determined from a mix of
eyewitness accounts and Hospital
surveillance footage that everyone
infected with the mysterious pathogen
had all been in a particular section of
the Maternity Ward earlier in the day
and when the operatives investigated
this area they found another strange
detail an infant had no registered
mother present in the hospital the
foundation would later learn that this
was likely because the baby's mother was
the first victim of the death disease
after eliminating all other possible
options it seemed that the only
anomalous element that could have caused
all of this was the mysterious baby
though just how the mother even survived
carrying the baby to term was a mystery
in and of itself the baby was a
Caucasian male human infant between 7
and 8 months of age nothing appeared
outwardly anomalous about the child but
they could confirm that every single
victim of the anomalous pathogen had
come into physical contact with the
child earlier that day everyone who had
been at the hospital was given amnestic
treatment and the foundation constructed
plausible cover stories for the deaths
that had occurred that day like so many
others before it the child was secured
and Spirited Away to the nearest
applicable Foundation containment site
there it was reclassified SCP 734 and
finally the real testing into what
precisely this infant was capable of
could begin physiologically SCP 734
appeared mostly nonanomalous the infant
had above average intelligence and
physical aptitude for a child his age
but otherwise showed no mutations or
abnormalities that would suggest a
Divergence from typical human biology
despite a vast array of tests performed
by the foundation into essentially every
aspect of 734 biology they couldn't find
anything that hinted at the origin of
the mysterious pathogen but through some
trial and extremely costly error the
foundation was able to learn more about
how exactly the pathogen worked the only
Vector for transmission seemed to be
direct contact with the baby itself up
to and including the fluids and residues
it leaves behind those affected cannot
transmit the anomalous flaking effect to
others meaning the risk of an epidemic
is relieving minimal but of course
accidents still happen as was discovered
when one agent misplaced her Sympathy
for the baby and decided to remove her
mask while interacting with him her
logic was that her masked face might
have caused the baby some kind of
distress and as long as she was only
coming into contact with him via her own
gloved hands everything would be fine
but some dust particles were floating in
the air at the time and SCP 734 sneezed
in her face the agent began screaming in
pain and recoiling from the baby but it
was already too late her fate was sealed
she was taken to the infirmary and given
sedatives so that she could hopefully
die in as little pain as possible in
roughly 72% of cases amputation of the
affected areas has prevented the entire
body from succumbing to the anomalous
effects of SCP 734 but this isn't
exactly feasible where the point of
contact is the victim's head within
hours the agent's flesh had flaked off
her face leaving her looking like a red
bloody skull a few hours after that she
didn't have a head at all throughout the
disintegration process of this
unfortunate agent the foundation took
grizzly photographs these photographs
are shown to anyone preparing to work on
the SCP 734 research project to teach
them a hard lesson on the importance of
adhering to proper safety protocols and
these protocols about how to deal with
the baby are incredibly tight given that
even incidental contact is often a death
sentence anyone entering the baby's
containment chamber needs to wear
contained atmosphere hazmat suits anyone
who makes physical contact with the baby
even when suited up is immediately
removed from the area and subject to
several hours of quarantine and
observation even inanimate objects that
have been inside the containment chamber
need to be thoroughly sterilized before
being removed given that even anomalous
children like SCP 734 have very delicate
needs a Handler is always standing by in
full Hazmat gear to take care of the
baby these handlers are rotated every
hour to maintain alertness and safety
these handlers feed and change as CP P
734 regularly and sometimes even provide
toys that have been approved by the 05
Council the foundation has gone to Great
Lengths to keep SCP 734 alive and
comfortable because they believe that
SCP 734 could be an important asset for
them in the future or more specifically
they see great strategic value in SCP
734 blood as mentioned earlier contact
with any matter from SCP 734 triggers
its deadly anomalous effect
including bodily fluids like blood but
unlike many toxic pathogens in this case
there is no risk of the infection
getting out of control since the
infected do not become vectors for
transmission because of this the blood
of SCP 734 can act as a powerful weapon
for both terminating anomalies deemed
unviable by the 05 Council and
assassinating dangerous people who
belong to rival groups contact with the
blood would completely destroy the
target's body with no other anomalous
effects and no evidence of who exactly
conducted the hit SCP 734 has been
fitted with an arterial catheter so that
the foundation can collect large
quantities of blood from the anomalous
infant every single week for storage and
research but it isn't just the blood
that the foundation sees potential in
SCP 734 himself has scored incredibly
well on the eslinger Loyalty index the
test the foundation uses to judge the
Loyalty of potential applicants to the
foundation cause as SCP 734 matures if
these scores remain consistent he will
likely be trained to become a foundation
field agent in the future an agent
capable of killing someone with a touch
would needless to say be an asset to
certain covert missions that the
foundation would probably prefer to keep
off the books of course the SCP
Foundation recruiting certain compliant
anomalies to perform missions for them
is far from unprecedented the most
infamous of these is SCP 076 also known
as Abel a supernatural eternally
resurrecting swordsman and perhaps one
of the finest Warriors who ever lived
the foundation took note of this and
channeled his eternal thirst for battle
into working with his very own mobile
task force he could assist in missions
by taking out his blood lust on enemy
groups of interest and dangerous
anomalies however this ended up working
a little too well and led to disaster
Abel was so good at his job that he
burned through all of his allotted
Missions at Aston ising speed left with
nothing more to do AEL got ansy which
led him to turning his murderous desires
on his fellow team members and then the
foundation as a whole it was an allout
Massacre before his colleagues were
finally able to kill him and return him
to containment the failure of this
initiative gave the very idea of letting
anomalies work for the foundation in the
field a bad name but since then things
have changed especially with the
establishment of MTF Alpha 9 AKA Last
Hope a new mobile task force formed
entirely of anomalous individuals and
their handlers these consist of somewhat
more stable anomalies such as ael's
counterpart SCP 073 also known as Kane
cane cannot be harmed with any harm
befalling him simply being mirrored back
on his attacker and his vast array of
knowledge makes him an incredibly useful
intelligent asset another of the several
members of Last Hope is Iris also known
as SCP 105 much like Kan Iris not only
has anomalous powers that make her
immensely valuable for missions in the
field she's also compliant and capable
of listening to reason unlike Kane her
abilities include being able to actively
surveil and even interact with photos of
any location especially when taken with
her anomalous camera someday SCP 734
could count himself among other
anomalous Foundation agents like these
providing he continues to show promise
and doesn't develop a like of the
foundation as he ages since after all he
won't be a baby forever so if you ever
find yourself on the foundation's bad
side you have a good reason to be
paranoid you'll have no idea that one
day the man who's going to kill you will
approach and shake your hand with a
smile it won't be until later when you
feel that strange tingle on your palm
and feel the skin starting to flake away
that you'll realize you've been a dead
man walking for hours what's in a name
ancient folklore and fairy tales
sometimes tell the importance of names
that they can hold the power to summon
or banish whether you buy into the
Superstition or not you'd be unwise to
ignore the power a name can have
especially if you ever dare to venture
into SCP 4000 why use your own name too
many times in this extradimensional
forest and you may find that what walks
out isn't you at all at least once a
year the foundation leads an expedition
into SCP 4000 to explore this keer class
dimension
but if you go down to those woods today
then you'd better follow the rules
remember the foundation has implemented
these guidelines for your own safety and
it's in your best interests to follow
them first and foremost when referencing
anything inside SCP 4000 be it a person
place or thing you cannot under any
circumstances use names or titles
communication is key when exploring SCP
4000 and making use of specific
descriptors will deter any adverse
effects on your journey for example you
may want to refer to the location of SCP
4000 as the woods where you need to
speak carefully an apt description for
such a place of course there is a reason
the foundation doesn't provide a handy
flash card of alternative descriptors
for any Personnel taking part in the
annual Mission into SCP 4000 nothing
found there can be referred to with any
consistent name so it's perhaps
advisable to look over a thesaurus and
expand your vocabulary before visiting
SCP 4000 as you'll need to come up with
a lot of different ways to refer to the
people and creatures around you but
don't worry the foundation will be able
to train you how to properly refer to
SCP 4000 in both written and verbal
communication in a similar vein the
second rule states that no Personnel
member should respond to their own name
while in SCP 4000 naturally you and your
fellow Expedition team will not be alone
in the forest you find yourselves in the
Denis of SCP 4000 are perpetually
mutating creatures some appearing to be
trustworthy While others are hostile it
is for personnel members own safety that
no consistent names or titles are used
to refer to each other in conf convers
ation this has been known to cause
Personnel returning from SCP 4000 to
experience Vivid hallucinations and in
some instances has led to the
appearances of creatures found in SCP
4000 in our world thirdly when
interacting with the life forms residing
in SCP 4000 Personnel are advised to
accept any gifts that they're offered
but are warned to under no circumstances
consume anything that is given to them
while inside the forest finally and
above all do not divulge any name
nickname Coden name Alias or any other
personal designation when interacting
with any native entities and disregard
any designator that an inhabitant of SCP
4000 attempts to assign to you personnel
must however remain courteous in the
presence of any native creature of SCP
4000 and treat these entities with
respect and formality access to SCP 4000
can only be achieved by performing
procedure 4,000 hallway a ritual
requiring a steady flame in an indoor
fireplace fueled by only organic
kindling Personnel are required to
combine the powdered bones of one male
lion one male red fox and a Bine whale
and cast these into the fire with a
personal possession holding strong
sentimental value to the staff member
performing 4,000 hallway next Personnel
are to add three feathers of a bird such
as a raven or Crow and must respond with
the correct counter phrases once the
fire begins to emit a voice if these
conditions are met and the correct
response is given Foundation Personnel
will gain access to the entry point of
SCP 4000 if any error is made during the
course of Performing procedure your
4,000 hallway then under no
circumstances should this ritual be
repeated staff are urged to apologize
for any incorrect actions then refrain
from engaging this procedure in the
future should procedure 4,000 Hall be
completed successfully Foundation
Personnel will find themselves arriving
in the access point to SCP 4000 emerging
from the mouth of an old well in the
center of the forest exploration teams
sent into SCP 4000 are advised that this
Dimension does not adhere to the laws of
physical space that Personnel will be
accustomed to there is a single
confirmed Med safe route that must be
used when traversing The Forest of SCP
4000 a dirt path leading in a circuit
both beginning and terminating at the
entry point previous attempts to map the
landscape of SCP 4000 all confirm that
the only way to safely exit this
Dimension is to follow the entire length
of the path in One Direction until
eventually returning to the well you
have been warned any attempt to travel
back to the direction you came in will
result in a loss of contact with the
rest of the Expedition team as mentioned
SCP 4000 is home to another number of
entities often noted to be undergoing
continuous and dramatic changes in form
these physiological mutations appear to
occur whenever these creatures are
unobserved making distinguishing between
them difficult when questioned about the
exact nature of these changes the
inhabitants of SCP 4000 claim to have no
control over them and express distress
and dissatisfaction when said changes
occur guidelines have been put in place
by the foundation regarding the
interactions between personnel and
creatures found in the forest and
adhering to the rules regarding the use
of consistent names and titles remains
vitally important the native creatures
appear semi-humanoid and are reported to
be highly temperamental should any staff
member happen to offend one of these
natives they may be subjected to
anything from verbal assault to acts of
extreme physical violence from the SCP
4000 resident if any foundation
Personnel further question why there are
so many rules when visiting SCP 4000
then they need to look no further than
the discoveries and fate of Dr Eugene
japers who during his initial expedition
to SCP 4000 in 200 5 encountered a
humanoid native entity whose head
resembled a rabbits as the pair shared a
polite conversation the rabbit-like
creature made an inquiry regarding Dr
japers name asking how was your name
keeping to the rules Dr japers did not
divulge any name or other form of title
to the creature at this time however
japers remained courteous and polite
during the interaction the rabbit
responded with the following are you
simple I'm merely asking how your name
is my name has smelled of raspberries
lately I think or snapdragons perhaps
it's so hard hard to tell these days but
one makes an effort in his reply Dr
japers made a reference to his own name
as having tasted rather tart as of late
before concluding the conversation with
the Rabbid entity Upon returning to the
SCP 4004s 3 years later Dr japers was
met with the same creature and once
again engaged in conversation with it
after briefly discussing their previous
encounter Dr jabbers was able to turn
their exchange towards something the
rabbit had mentioned before about
finding it difficult to describe his own
name when asked to clarify this point
the rabbit replied I can only assume
it's because of how long we've been
apart my name and I that is it's a good
name a proud name I'm fairly sure by
this point though it's probably decayed
from its former Grandeur if it even
still exists after this mention of its
relationship with its own name it should
be noted that the rabbit referred to Dr
japers by the title fellow scholar the
third and final encounter between Dr
japers and this entity came in 2013
after the doctor was sent into SCP 4000
with instructions to conduct a more
thorough interview with the subject it
was during their third conversation that
the rabbit man revealed details of a
long forgotten war between human beings
and the residents of SCP 4000 apparently
these creatures the Fay do not originate
from the forest in which they now reside
and according to the rabbit man's claims
were born in our world much as it
Grieves me to say we were betrayed the
rabbit explained we had fought side by
side you know in the war against that
factory we had done nothing but help
them and what did they do they destroyed
us they took so many of our lives and
all of our names some of us fled here
when the war was just beginning but not
many not many still though I don't hate
them it has been assumed by some that
the foundation was directly involved in
whatever may have wiped out the Fay
causing them to either Retreat or be
banished to the forest of SCP 4000 an
additional assumption has been made that
whatever weapons were used on these
creatures is directly responsible for
their constantly shifting State
rendering them without their own names
or identities whatever the case may be
it was during their conversation that Dr
japers in reference to their second
encounter referred to himself as a
fellow fellow scholar to the rabbit in
order to coax information from him
however in doing so the doctor had
unwittingly accepted the title that the
native entity had given him by
mistakenly responding to the name fellow
scholar the doctor had broken the rules
of interacting with the creatures of SCP
4000 an easy mistake but a costly one
the doctor would later leave SCP 4000
traversing the safe path back to the
well and Dr japers vanished shortly
after his exit from SCP 4000 his
whereabouts are currently unknown the
foundation has made several attempts to
investigate his timely disappearance but
to this day he remains missing and the
fur left on the inside of his expedition
gear displayed no strange properties the
single goal it would seem of the
creatures residing in SCP 4000 is the
theft of names however this naturally
extends far beyond the dimensions
definition of identity theft though an
unfortunate blunder Dr japers allowed
the friendly nature and demeanor of the
rabbit entity to trick him into
accepting the name fellow scholar by
giving Dr japers a name the rabbit was
free to steal not only his name but his
very identity while while it is unclear
how this transference is achieved by the
creatures it is due to the risk of this
that the foundation employs such strict
rules for any research team tasked with
traveling to the forest of SCP 4000 make
no mistake names have more power than we
realize and this is evident in few
places more so than SCP 4000 a pocket
Dimension where everchanging survivors
of a forgotten Massacre exist as
identities alone remember a name is a
powerful thing whichever side of the
well you find yourself on your name
binds you to who you are but if your
name becomes someone else's then one
else of yours becomes theirs too it all
started in 1983 with reports of human
trafficking in the heart of Sin City the
FBI had gotten word of a potential
trafficking ring operating out of an
abandoned department store in Las Vegas
Nevada and immediately began organizing
a secret raid on the building while they
would indeed encounter something
horrifying within that abandoned
Apartment Store it wasn't criminals or
human trafficking in fact it wasn't n
human at all this is the horrifying
story of SCP 847 after weeks of planning
the raid on the department store was
conducted in the dead of night agents
covered all the exits and entrances and
a helicopter was stationed nearby in
case anyone attempted to run it should
have been a perfect trap but things
never go as planned when you don't know
what you're dealing with the agents
breached the door and began searching
the darkened building it didn't appear
that there was any power so the the
traffickers must have had great night
vision and a high tolerance for creepy
locals agents soon heard a faint humming
sound coming from below a generator it
must be located in the basement and be
the Hub of this criminal Enterprise
readying themselves for whatever they
were about to find the agents descended
into the basement as they moved deeper
into the building they found that
lighting rigs had been set up they must
be getting closer to something but that
something was still a mystery a senior
FBI specialist agent was leading the
charge his pistol drawn and ready it was
quiet too quiet did the traffickers
already realize they were coming and
clear out he was ready to consider this
bust to bust when he heard a quiet muing
in the distance a persistent whining
whimper that was undeniably human he
gave the signal to his fellow agents to
follow the noise they proceeded forward
towards the pain sounds and found
themselves in a wide well-lit room
filled with department store mannequins
all were broken to some degree some were
totally smashed to Pieces some were
chained to walls and locked in cages
others were wrapped in plastic the agent
wondered whether this was some kind of
Twisted joke or a messed up avantguard
art piece that's when he noticed her a
single Crouch figure in the distance
hunched over and whimpering in a
darkened corner of the room near a
fulllength mirror he couldn't fully make
her out but he got the sense that
something was wrong she was injured Ed
bent over was she even missing an arm
just what have these monsters done to
this woman he whispered a request for
backup Into His Radio and pushed on when
he got within 50 m of this strange woman
her demeanor changed entirely she jerked
around her movements forced erratic and
painful looking the woman stared
directly into the agent's eyes and began
hobbling towards him occasionally
stopping to strike a pose as if modeling
during a photo shoot just then the agent
made a horrifying realization this thing
moving towards them wasn't a woman at
all it was a living mannequin as she got
closer though he realized that the
mannequin's broken left forearm had been
carved into a large shiv a female Junior
FBI agent had been one of the many to
pour into the room when the raid leader
had radioed for backup the second she
entered the 50 m range of this strange
mannequin everything changed in an
instant its eyes and mouth began
dripping with a thick viscous resin its
whimpering gasps suddenly became vicious
earsplitting screeches and it turned its
gaze from the senior FBI agent it was
now focused on the junior agent who had
just entered the room and broke into a
terrifying run straight towards her the
mannequin moved with a violent
single-minded purpose other agents began
firing but it was running freakishly
fast and easily dodged most of the
bullets the few that actually hit seemed
to do nothing to slow the creature down
it Shrugged off the damage and kept
running with a great leap it landed on
the terrified Junior agent and began
jabbing her with its bladed arm the
other agent stopped firing fearing they
might accidentally hit their colleague
during the Panic the mannequin was
ruthless clawing and stabbing with the
strange resin leaking out of its every
orifice terrified and unable to reach
her gun the agent remembered her
training she reached into her belt and
grabbed her stun gun jamming the two
probes up against the creature's chest
and giving it 30,000 and volts the
creature spasmed fell backwards and
collapsed in a heap on the ground Frozen
this was the first recorded encounter
with SCP 847 a violent living mannequin
with a serious problem with women this
terrifying report was passed up the
chain of command until it landed on the
desk of a foundation agent working in
the FBI the foundation quickly swooped
in and claimed the mannequin delivered
necessary amnestic treatment to all who'
witnessed it and closely observed the
female J your FBI agent's recovery in a
private hospital with Foundation ties as
it turns out they were right to do so as
the junior agent was in for a gruesome
fate while the wound she'd suffered at
the hands of SCP 847 didn't appear fatal
the fact that the mannequin's anomalous
resin excretions entered the open wound
changed everything several hours after
being committed the junior agent began
complaining of limb stiffness and
difficulty moving this quickly developed
into full paralysis
over time her skin and internal organs
began to harden until the process dub
plastination came to a grusome end the
junior agent wasn't just dead she had
been transformed into a mannequin
Foundation researchers were met with a
truly horrifying realization this means
that all the other Broken Mannequins
found with SCP 847 were likely once
living humans attacked and transformed
by the anomaly now a source for new
harvested body parts now safely interred
at a foundation containment facility
though the real tests on SCP 847 to
determine its behavior and physical
attributes could begin the most
important detail about SCP 847 is that
its aggression is exclusively directed
towards women as opposed to when it
encounters men and its instincts are
more self-destructive through a series
of tests and observations researchers
have been able to pin down three
different different distinct patterns of
behavior for SCP 847 pattern Z behaviors
occur when there are no humans standing
within 50 m of SCP 847 the mannequin
will seek out a fulllength mirror and
pose in front of it much like a
department stor mannequin attempting to
show off its clothes it remains largely
inanimate during these periods and will
very occasionally use a finger or
whatever appendage is available given
its habit for self-mutilation to scratch
messages on nearby surfaces pattern y
Behavior occurs when male humans with XY
chromosomes enter a 50 m radius around
SCP 847 just like its reaction to the
male FBI agents who found it 847 will
initially emit vocalizations that seem
like whimpering gasps before making eye
contact and striking provocative poses
while approaching the subject it will
then remain static and allow the male
subject to pose its body however after
the male subject leaves the area 847
will enter a state of considerable
distress and begin removing or
shattering parts of its body the
foundation has found that the parts
removed or shattered are often
consistent with parts that the male
subjects found displeasing during
interactions showing a masochistic
desire to impress these parts are then
harvested back from plastinated victims
which brings us to the most dangerous of
Its Behavior patterns pattern X
behaviors occur when female humans enter
a 50 m radius surround the creature 847
will immediately become brutally
aggressive switching its noises from
whimpers to violent screeches and growls
847 experiences enhanced physical
capabilities during pattern X states its
speed has been measured at 45 kmph
making it as fast as the legendary SCP
096 it's also been shown to exhibit
extreme physical strength it's during
this pattern of behavior that it begins
excreting its deadly resin which which
has been proven to only be dangerous to
women in these states the only thing
capable of reliably pacifying the being
is a powerful electric shock the shock
causes the creature's resin to harden
temporarily incapacitating it for
roughly 5 minutes other Conventional
Weapons and damage has no meaningful
effect on SCP 847 after a number of
incidents that had sad and violent
endings the foundation Ethics Committee
forbade the use of female d-class
personnel an SCP 847 testing when it
came to female subjects 847 always
slipped into a state of extreme
aggression so instead the foundation
began testing with male subjects in
hopes of better understanding the
Dynamics between human males and SCP 847
various misogynistic d-class males were
introduced into the containment chamber
which was modeled to look like a bedroom
for the purposes of Behavioral study
each one either during or after their
interaction with SCP 847 was told to
comment on some aspect they felt
dissatisfied with the mannequin
shattered its own chest after hearing it
described as being out of proportion
after another d-class called its nose
ugly the mannequin broke it off after
another said that its hair was out of
fashion and commented on its inability
to drink it tore out its hair and liver
all parts were replaced after the
experiments things took their most
violent and upsetting turn yet with the
introduction of D7
294 a lot of the time d-class Personnel
are considered to be as Anonymous as
they are expendable but
d724 is an exception before becoming
d-class he was a successful cello
teacher who brutally murdered one of his
teenage students and her mother he's
typically employed in tests when the
foundation wishes to see interactions
between anomalies and humans with
confirmed Psychopathic personalities
during his interaction with SCP 847 he
belittled and hum humiliated the
mannequin he forced it into
uncomfortable poses and even snapped off
one of its fingers before being dragged
from the room by Foundation guards in
the following debrief he further berated
the mannequin as useless and lousy at
its job of being controlled by him in
response 847 extracted its own brains
eyes and clavicle before shattering its
own hands in dismay so why does 847
behave this way while it may appear
monstrous it seems that the reason SCP
847 does what it does is All Too Human
it hurts women because it itself is
hurting and it's willing to hurt itself
even more for the approval of the
objects of its desire as a result it's
an anomaly trapped in an endless cycle
of pain and violence perhaps one day
it'll be able to free itself from the
loop but that day is unlikely to come
for this murderous mannequin anytime
soon the year was 1983 and 7-year-old
Andrea Bradbury was wandering the
streets of Nashville Tennessee one of
her favorite activities was to head down
to the local movie theater and fantasize
about the movie she'd one day be old
enough to see this fateful weekend
Andrea's local theater was playing a
brand new release jaws 3D what she
didn't know is that this simple innocent
activity would bring little Andrea into
dangerous contact with SCP 178 and
change her life forever jaws 3D isn't
exactly a classic it was one of the many
forgettable sequels pumped out to cash
in on the 3D craze of the early 1980s
people paid extra for the privilege of
sitting in the dark with an
uncomfortable pair of cardboard glasses
while cheesy effects leapt out of the
screen towards them many of the movie
goers simply threw away the cheap
disposable glasses as soon as they left
the theater leaving them scattered on
the sidewalk outside seeing a pair of 3D
glasses on the ground right there for
the taking was the highlight of little
Andrea's week she may not have been old
enough to see any of the movies but she
knew that a local shop sold books with
images that popped out of the page with
a simple pair of 3D glasses excited by
the prospect of getting to experience 3D
Andrea grabbed a pair of glasses and ran
straight for the bookstore later that
night she was in her bedroom with a
stereoscopic image of a ferris wheel
Andrea adjusted the glasses and the
ferris wheel really did pop right off
the page she marveled that the image
coming out of the book and felt like she
could almost touch it but suddenly a
strange feeling came over her she had
the feeling that she wasn't alone still
wearing the glasses Andrea looked up
from her book and saw it standing in the
corner of her room something huge
something
monstrous Andrea's parents heard her
scream and came rushing into her room
there was their little girl dead it
looked like she'd been mauled to death
by a wild animal but there was no sign
of her killer the windows were shut
tight unable to be opened from the
outside it was like whatever horrible
creature had done this had vanished Into
Thin Air the coroner's report didn't
give any other Clues as to who could
have done this except that whoever or
whatever had murdered her it appeared to
have three long and Incredibly sharp
claws the terrible tragedy of Andrea's
death rocked Nashville but it never made
the national papers why because the SC P
Foundation was immediately on the case
undercover agents in the US fish and
wildlife service flagged the strange
death as anomalous and SCP field
Personnel arrived to do their own
investigation of the crime scene there
they quickly discovered Andrea's 3D
glasses which would eventually be
classified as SCP
178 an agent looked over the glasses
there didn't seem to be anything out of
the ordinary about them just your
regular cardboard frames with blue and
red tinted film over the eyes everything
about them seemed normal so he tried the
glasses on for himself he picked up the
open book off the ground where Andrea
had likely dropped it and saw the ferris
wheel pop off the page nothing abnormal
until he turned his head slightly he saw
the head of some kind of thing only an
inch away from his own looking over his
shoulder at the book being a trained SCP
agent he maintained his composure and
looked around the room as he did he saw
that several other creatures were
standing and watching none of the rest
of the recovery team seemed to notice
the creatures and when the agent removed
SCP 178 they vanished it appeared they
had found whatever had caused Andrea
Bradbury staff the glasses were
immediately taken to the nearest
Foundation containment site for further
testing seeing these mysterious entities
through SCP 178 may have answered one
question but it raised many others what
are these creatures were they real or
merely Illusions created by a SCP
178 if they are real are they somehow
summoned by SCP 178 or simply revealed
by them there was already one death that
could be tied to the glasses with some
certainty but just how dangerous were
they the SCP Foundation was about to
find out Foundation scientists devised a
series of experiments with a test
chamber separated from an adjoining
observation chamber by a panel of
reinforced bulletproof glass a member of
d-class personnel was placed into the
test chamber along with SCP 178 he was
instructed to put on the glasses and
report back what he saw to the
researchers the d-class followed the
orders however when he did so he quickly
entered a state of extreme distress he
threw away the glasses and covered his
eyes screaming wildly when ordered to
compose himself and explain what he saw
under threat of termination the d-class
described a hideous creature standing
close to his face watching when asked to
elaborate he described it as having too
many eyes after that the d-class refused
to put the glasses back on again despite
direct orders and threats from
Foundation staff he was then removed
from the test chamber and observed
although he experienced 2 days of mild
paranoia after 30 total days of
observation the d-class was found to
have no lasting psychological effects
disappointed by the meager results of
the first test the researchers had at
least confirmed that they did have an
anomalous object in their possession
and pressed on with experimentation they
used the same methodology again on
another d-class she was placed into the
chamber and instructed to put on SCP 178
then described The Entity she saw in
great detail when she put on the glasses
she recoiled in horror at the monster
she saw staring back at her she said
that the creature was tall and bipedal
with two additional upper appendages
ending in large conical protrusions she
also described the creature's head as
being smooth smooth when asked if the
creature exhibited any kind of
aggression or hostility she said that it
was completely still it was just
standing there after a few minutes
though the creature seemed to lose
interest and begin staring at the wall
the researchers were happy to learn more
about the creature's physicality but
they still weren't confident that it
wasn't just an illusion created by the
glasses they needed to engineer an
interaction for the next experiment they
decided to alter the particulars a fract
blue and red image in a similar style to
the stereoscopic ferris wheel from the
book Andrea had purchased was fixed to
one wall against the opposite wall they
placed a bucket containing 10 standard
tennis balls this time the d-class a
convicted murderer and arsonist was told
he was helping to test a new 3D
augmented reality project the entities
he would see as far as he knew were
little more than digital projections
though when he actually wore SCP 178 and
saw them he commented that whoever
designed them must be crazy the
researchers instructed the d-class to
pick up a tennis ball and throw it at
one of the entities the second he did so
deep lacerations began appearing all
over his body the onslaught was brutal
and quick and the d-class was dead soon
after that this confirmed to the
researchers that the creatures did seem
to have some level of tangible presence
and they could be extremely violent if
provoked next they wished to see if it
was possible to have any kind of
interaction with the creatures without
it immediately descending into violence
to test this Theory the researchers
brought a 19-year-old d-class into the
testing chamber under the same pretense
of testing new 3D
technology much like the others she was
still horrified by the appearance of the
creatures but was calmed down by the
researchers they asked her to speak to
the creatures directly without
exhibiting any kind of aggression she
said hello weird thing how are you today
in a somewhat bored voice and this was
all all it took to sign her death
warrant she was immediately slashed to
death by invisible creatures the results
seemed clear any interaction whatsoever
with the creatures while wearing SCP 178
was a death sentence like a slightly
more outgoing shy guy but the
researchers would soon find that this
anomaly had even more
surprises for their next test they
brought in two subjects one would wear
SCP 178 and dictate to the other how
they should interact with the creature
they could not see the results of this
experiment were bloody yet informative
both subjects were slashed to death when
the unseeing d-class interacted with one
of the creatures on her companion's
instructions it appeared that anyone
with sufficient knowledge of the
creatures who attempts to interact with
them is doomed even if they can't
directly see one of them it was an
upsetting realization for the
researchers SCP 178 may be much more
dangerous than they initially imagined
and what they learn in the next
experiment was even worse
they adopted the same methodology as the
last for the following experiment two
subjects one seeing and the other
interacting however this time as soon as
subject number one put on the glasses
they knew that something was terribly
wrong he began panicking stating that
the entire chamber was full of the
creatures all standing and watching the
researchers undertook these experiments
knowing that they didn't often turn out
well for the d-class so they didn't seem
too worried about this new development
that is until the subject stated that
they could see three more of the
creatures and they weren't in the test
chamber they were in the observation
room in fact one of them was looking
right over one of the three researchers
shoulders immediately the researchers
lost composure and began to panic they
were used to putting d-class in danger
that was part of the job but they
weren't prepared for this in just
moments the observation room became a
bloodbath as the three researchers who'd
been designing and Performing all the
experiments were torn to Pieces by
creatures they couldn't see SCP 178 had
gone from being one of the more innocent
looking anomalies to one of the most
mysterious and deadly the creatures seem
to be powerful violent and Incredibly
numerous the fact that they can only be
observe through 178 stereoscopic lenses
and kill anyone who even attempts to
interact with them makes them almost
impossible to understand it was always a
tragedy when the foundation lost good
researchers but the work must continue
and the experiments were soon restarted
with increased safety measures of course
those didn't do much good and after
another disastrous experiment that
resulted in the whole sector getting
locked down all research into SCP 178
was placed under increased scrutiny they
needed to find some way of observing the
creatures without the risk of having to
share space with them the proposed
solution was seeing if the SCP 178
glasses were compatible with camera
technology for remote viewing much like
all stereoscopic glasses they found that
looking through only one lens at a time
was ineffective the solution was
relatively simple a dual lens camera in
a roughly similar configuration to human
eyes this however didn't give them the
Comfort or the answers they hoped for
researchers commented upon finally
seeing the creatures that they were even
more hideous than they'd ever imagined
as they observed a victim interacting
with the creatures via their new camera
they found that as soon as the creatures
were interacted with in any way they
would grow three long Claws and attack
and they were as fast as they were
ferocious from the observations there
were only a few things that the
foundation now knew about them for sure
their physical appearance their violent
nature their enhanced physical abilities
and the fact they appear to be pretty
much everywhere and who knows how long
they'd been here observing us humans
while we glided by them ignorant to
their presence it's enough to make you
think twice before putting on a pair of
3D glasses again but of course never
putting on the glasses doesn't mean
you're safe just knowing about them puts
you in danger they could be standing
next to you right now looking over your
shoulder as you watch this video just
remember if you want to be safe you
can't ever let them know you're aware
after all just because you can't see
something doesn't mean it can't hurt ask
yourself a simple question is the world
around you real it seems like the answer
should be pretty obvious of course the
world as you know it is real how else
would you be able to interact with it
perhaps a better question would be this
how much do you trust that the world you
know is real how much do you believe
that reality as you experience it is
constant and cannot be changed by
external
forces now imagine if you can an entity
to which the very fabric of reality is
like clay able to be shaped and molded
at will then imagine that this entity
this malicious twisted and unknowable
horror has taken a special interest in
you if you can picture such a scenario
then you may as well be standing in the
shoes of James tallaran a foundation
researcher assigned to SCP
39.99 Taran could only have imagined
what the foundation kept contained in an
airtight cell all the way at the bottom
of a kilometer long shaft and never
expected that this was where his
lifeless body would be found despite
having the entity contained the
foundation's only knowledge of SCP 3999
came from a text document discovered on
Tan's phone after his demise even their
own records indicated that no such
creature ever existed why what could
possibly shape reality in such a way
that it could hide its own existence
from the
foundation and where was it now the
document on Tan's phone yielded some
evidence seeming to be a long rambling
and Confused account of of some sort of
battle between a reality shaping entity
and the ill- fated researchers sent to
examine it unlike many of the
foundation's documents the entry for SCP
3999 is riddled with contradictions and
strikethroughs a confusing mess of
information that makes piecing together
the mysteries of talin's Fate all the
more difficult beneath the strange
formatting and uncertainty surrounding
SCP 3999 lies the tale of one man's
torture for the amusement of an
impossible posibly powerful and
eternally sadistic creature based on the
information available it appears that
SCP 3999 was fixated on tallaran upon
his arrival to the entity's cell the
researcher had no idea how long he would
spend in the company of SCP 3999 or that
he would never emerge alive many scps
contained by the foundation require
their own specially made prisons in
order to hold them and maintain the
safety of foundation staff as well as
the outside side world but imagine if an
SCP could turn the tables bending the
world around a single member of the
foundation using all of reality as their
own personalized torture chamber the
list of Horrors endured by Taran is both
exhaustive and incomplete given the
length of time he spent with the
creature shortly after James Taran was
assigned to site 118 where SCP 3999 was
contained The Entity was somehow able to
breach containment and began to twist
the world around it in the name of a
singular cruel objective the torture of
James
Taran the creature while having no
physical description possessed the
capability to cause either a CK class
reality restructuring event or a ZK
Class end of reality event SCP 3999 was
somehow able to both destroy reality
itself while simultaneously rebuilding
it around its prisoner researcher
tallaran Every Creature person and
machination that SC P 3999 created was
done so with the express intention of
making tolerant suffer horribly over the
course of millions of years according to
the researchers own writings the exact
details of how SCP 3999 tortured Taran
are littered throughout the document he
was found with but it is apparent that
the entity was able to use its reality
altering abilities to continually revive
the man after killing him as a way to
prolong his pain SCP 39 99 seemed to be
able to use its powers however it
pleased but focused all its attention
and actions on causing misery for one
man it simply enjoyed inflicting
suffering one of the examples of the
atrocities James Talan suffered at the
mercy of a cold remorseless creature was
witnessing the deaths of others although
they were constructed and controlled by
SCP
3999 Toran saw Train Foundation security
Personnel drag three people into the
cell he recognized them instantly as his
own family tallaran was made to watch as
his mother father and sister were
executed with a single gunshot to the
head by members of the same organization
that he was a part of all of taran's
professional colleagues were also killed
in front of him followed by anyone and
everyone that had come into contact with
James tallaran including the 05 Council
he was made to watch as they were
systematically murdered one by one all
for the enjoyment of SCP
39.99 at some point during the creatures
torture of Taran there appears to have
been some attempt to contain SCP 39.99
within another SCP SCP
2432 a room within a hotel now owned by
the foundation that appears to compel
its guests to write exaggerated positive
reviews after staying there when
introduced to SCP
2432 SCP 3999 ability to alter reality
seemed to have the effect of creating a
dimensional anomaly within the hotel a
crawl space opened up in SCP 2432
leading to an almost identical room the
front door of this new room designated
SCP
24321 led to an alternate Dimension that
resembled the hotel housing SCP
2432 the rooms of this new version of
the SCP 2432 Hotel were a seemingly
infinite endless loop of rooms this
Dimension also played host to a number
of strange creatures has uncovered by
Foundation research teams that ventured
there most notably a creature resembling
a male Homo Sapien calling itself
researcher tallaran this being was
dressed in clothing similar to
Foundation researchers and appeared
nervous and confused when approached by
personnel only to be executed when as to
be told the location of SCP
3999 later during SCP 39 99's 3 milliony
year torture session James tallaran was
interviewed with another doctor working
for the
foundation the interviewing doctor had
no recollection of taran's assignment to
SCP
3999 and both James's involvement with
the foundation and the Very existence of
SCP 3999 work sponge from the
foundation's database as tallaran
desperately tried to rationalize what
was happening to him he told the
interviewer I have trouble focusing on
things now I just feel a lot of unease
it's like reality has started to feel
less real if that makes sense shortly
after he attempted to ask the doctor for
his name and for him to identify which
of the foundation sites they were at in
response the doctor emitted a strange
noise from his mouth confusing Taran
that's not a name you just made a noise
with your mouth the researcher replied
why am I thinking of redactions how can
a word be redacted like that in a normal
conversation following this the floor
beneath James taran's feet disappeared
and he was swallowed by Darkness as SC P
3999 continued bending reality to make
him suffer What followed were multiple
failed attempts from tallaran to either
Escape From The Entity or nullify its
abilities to warp reality SCP 3999 had
at a later Point trapped Taran in a
stage playay version of itself as James
frantically tried to escape out of a
nearby door where he hoped to find
reality he was met with a solid wall I'm
trapped in whatever this place is with
this thing and there's no outside
reality anymore he realized researcher
Taran tried to understand the entity but
SCP 3999 defied description it was
simply chaos in his desperation Toran
was able to dig a tiny hole in the floor
through which he could see a lie filled
with thoughts of his beloved family his
colleagues and the rest of the world
that had once existed he opened the hole
wider it is unclear what happened after
this but it is apparent that James
tallaran was still unable to escape SCP
39 99 however as the situations he found
himself in grew increasingly strange
James Taran was able to take greater
control of his predicament this is
evidenced in the foundation's document
regarding SCP
3999 researcher tallaran cannot be
contained by this researcher Taran will
fight his way back researcher Taran will
recontain SCP
3999 this torture had gone on long
enough and researcher James tallaran was
deter deted to be free of the creature
that had taken such sick pleasure in his
pain Taran at one point was able to
subdue SCP
3999 although it is initially unclear
how we accomplished this there were
several attempts made to contain the
entity using a recursive joke a melon
the graves of American Crime novelist
Robert B Parker or an 05 council member
and a roach motel It is believed that
every single one of these attempts
failed attempting to beat the creature
at its own game Tarin tried to turn SC P
3999 reality altering Powers against it
by imagining The Entity as something
easier to subdue these included several
moldy blankets a murderous penguin and a
pillow eventually Taran was able to
contain SCP 3999 with the aid of 48
trained containment Personnel all of
whom were also researcher Talan during
this time a conversation between the two
were partially recorded although any
dialogue from SCP 3999 suffered from
data corruption
claiming to finally be in charge and in
control of the situation tallaran
interrogated SCP 3999 berading the
creature for keeping him prisoner you
can't frighten me anymore for the first
million years of nonsensical containment
procedures and tortures and dream logic
it was the worst pain I had ever felt
but I survived for the second million
years it was still the hardest thing I
had ever done but I survived by the
third million years I was grown growing
numb the researcher tried to ascertain
the exact nature and origin of SCP
3999 but to no avail vowing to fight The
Entity talin told it here's the thing
about horror and weirdness the more you
reveal of it the less effect it has I am
sick of your horror I am sick of you
afterwards he was melted into goo for 5
years it appears that shortly after this
researcher tan managed to understand how
to destroy SCP
3999 while the entity was Immortal and
virtually Unstoppable he realized its
weakness that it had to bond to another
being in order to survive upon
discovering this tallaran took his own
life causing all that SCP 3999 had done
to disappear after Foundation researcher
James tallaran committed suicide reality
reverted to its original state before
SCP 3999 had heavily altered it
his death freeing reality from the evil
entity once and for all the foundation
remains unaware of what sccp 3999 was or
indeed is and one can only guess as to
why the entity subjugated toin to such
Terror and horror what made this
powerful reality Bender hold such a
perverse fixation on one man some have
likened the creature to a horror writer
continually subjugating a character to
all manner of nightmares before deciding
to redraft and try something new
whatever it was SCP 3999 carries with it
a warning that reality isn't always as
it
seems it's a perfect day for a wedding
on a warm spring afternoon a bride and
the handsome groom are exchanging the
special Rings they had custom designed
and made for each other as they take
turns placing the rings on each other's
fingers a man standing at the end of the
wedding party steps out of position he
approaches the groomsman next to him and
reaches into his jacket taking out a
pair of pliers that he hands to the
groomsman the groomsman happily takes
the tool and then without any hesitation
shoves the pliers into his mouth and
begins removing his teeth one by one
when he is finished he hands the bloody
teeth to the man along with the pliers
the man then goes to the next groomsman
who repeats the same process he
continues going down the line until all
of the groomsmen and bridesmaids have
removed their teeth seemingly without
pain or resistance the man then
approaches the bride and groom he hands
each of them half of the pile of teeth
which they gladly accept they then begin
to eat the teeth without delay seemingly
not bothered by the intense damage
they're causing to their own teeth and
Jaws by doing so the man watches as the
groom moves the priest who was
officiating the wedding aside as the
entire church looks on in Joy the groom
opens his mouth and the deafening sound
of cicas are heard this is only the
beginning of what the SCP Foundation has
labeled an SCP 2852 event a terrifying
and little understood phenomenon that is
better known by the nickname of the
anomalous creature responsible for them
cousin Johnny the foundation had been
trying to contain cousin Johnny for
decades not that it ever done them any
good Johnny is a cutter class anomaly
that's thus far proven impossible to
contain this is an entity so dangerous
and volatile child that three different
mobile task forces are devoted to
detecting and disrupting its activities
MTF Upsilon 36 aka the party crashers
MTF Upsilon 52 AKA cater Duty and MTF
Upsilon 999 aka the alter boys but so
far all the foundation has been able to
really do is Swoop in afterwards and do
their best to pick up the pieces of
people's shattered lives cousin Johnny
has so far been observed to only operate
in the North American subcontinent and
only seems to appear at Anglican or
Catholic baptisms weddings and funerals
however Foundation operatives charge
with keeping a lid on cousin Johnny
Harbor the hidden fear that he may one
day expand his hunting grounds and wreck
Terror worldwide if Johnny became
multinational or multi-denominational
his violence insanity and pure evil May
truly become impossible to minimize so
compatible communities are constantly
monitored for increased levels of
juvenile delin y sterility domestic
violence and divorce after all this
you're probably wondering who or what
actually is cousin Johnny and how does
he cause so much horrific tragedy at
face value nothing about the appearance
of cousin Johnny would suggest an
anomalous nature or even any sort of
danger he appears to be a middle-aged
white male often with scruffy hair and a
beard on a cellular level two cousin
Johnny appears all too human but when
you look at his physiology it's a whole
different story cousin Johnny has no
identifiable organs whatsoever his body
is made out of a fibrous muscular tissue
the only exceptions are his teeth and
hair which are made out of a kind of
kiten a key component of insect
exoskeletons such as those possessed by
cicas Johnny's eyes are the first clue
that something is off about him from a
distance they appear perfectly normal
but up close they're glassy and dead
this is because his eyes aren't actually
attached to any nerves inside his head
with no nervous system or or vocal cords
Johnny's ability to see move and talk
defy any kind of logical explanation his
speech will seem completely normal to
the people under his spell but to anyone
else it comes out as complete nonsense
often described as word salad if people
in attendance are briefed in advance
about this phenomenon whatever hypnotic
ability causes them to hear his sounds
as intelligible words won't work and
they'll be aware of how nonsensical it
all sounds but of course that doesn't
mean there's safe cousin Johnny appears
at family gatherings and religious
rituals and immediately he'll be treated
as though he's always been there you
know your cousin Johnny right you go way
back or at least you're pretty sure you
do nothing will appear unnatural about
his sudden presence in fact if you're
one of the victims of one of his
incidents chances are you'll actually
find yourself taking a shine to cousin
Johnny sure his sense of humor is a
little crude and runchy but you can't
help but enjoy his company he's a fun
guy to be around and after all he's
family as previously mentioned he'll
only appear at three different kinds of
events baptisms weddings and funerals
and only those that are affiliated with
either the Catholic or Anglican
religions the SCP Foundation has
classified baptisms that cousin Johnny
attends as blue level events weddings
are known as white level events and
funerals are Black Level events with
each one escalating in severity violence
and horror first baptisms the blue level
events in these events cousin Johnny
will appear and begin to act as a third
god parent despite their traditionally
only being two as the infant is lowered
into the holy water the entirety of
their top layer of skin will come off
like a molting snake despite looking
horrific this apparently causes no harm
to the child the god parents will then
eat this discarded skin as though it's
the most normal thing in the world after
this the family will leave the church
together and cousin Johnny will leave
leave with them he won't appear at any
subsequent celebrations of the child's
baptism of course this is just the
beginning of the terror following cousin
Johnny's appearance at the baptism the
child's risk of dying in the next 6
months skyrockets and if they survive
they're at an increased risk of becoming
unstable and violent later on in life
their parents and godparents will both
become unable to conceive any further
children and are likely to be found dead
from drowning within 5 years of the
event those who are only tangentially
involved in the baptism ritual have a
massively increased chance of failed
pregnancies or if they do conceive they
may become a danger to their offspring
children who live through blue level
events and survive past adolescence will
experience adverse side effects when
encountering the songs of cicas well
into adulthood from experiencing
physical sickness to going through
dangerous psychotic episodes weddings or
wh level events are more complex and
severe in this case cousin Johnny will
insert himself into the wedding as a
groomsman and the most horrifying events
will begin to take place after the vows
have been exchanged Johnny will provide
various implements that allow the
Bridesmaids and groomsmen to remove
their teeth which are then given to the
bride and groom to eat which they do
causing severe damage to their own teeth
in the process the groom will then
vocalize an unknown cicada call at an
incredible volume as loud as 140 DB in
some instances rendering the bride and
everyone else near the alter completely
deaf at the wedding reception where
everyone is continuing to behave as if
nothing out of the ordinary is happening
cousin Johnny will ruin things farther
by giving the best man speech the speech
is more of his typical complete nonsense
though if you're there you'll never
realize this and think that this is the
best speech you've ever heard with some
in the audience laughing hysterically
While others cry uncontrollably once his
speech is done he'll present a gift to
the newly married couple 3.5 kg of human
hair and ious colors 13 deceased
specimens of a certain cicada known as
Lin cicada and 23 human teeth in a
cardboard box DNA tests on all the gifts
have been inconclusive as to their
origin much like many celebrity
marriages unions that occurred during
white level events Never Last and all
end up divorced within 2 years often as
a result of domestic violence and any
children born during their brief
marriage will be violent and unstable
but it's not just the wedding party that
gets to experience the fun of a visit
from cousin Johnny all married
individuals who attended the wedding
will find that they are unable to
conceive children despite no biological
indicators of infertility any children
present at the white level event will
show no interest in Romance throughout
their life and often die tragically
before reaching the age of 18 finally
and most horrifying of all are funerals
or black level events while blue and
white level events can potentially be
disrupted before they are completed
lessening or preventing the horrific
results there is as yet no way to stop
or prevent a black level event at any
stage any attempts to prevent cousin
Johnny from entering the church or
Funeral Home will lead him to Simply
manifesting inside once in the room
where the funeral is taking place cousin
Johnny will first take up the role of
eulogizer and begin speaking his
standard nonsense to the attendance the
person who was emotionally closest to
The Departed will then open the casket
if this was not already an open casket
funeral and will then produce a large
knife it's unknown where the knives come
from as they're not present before the
event and they disappear after the
funeral attendees will then use the
knife on their wrists and sometimes
throats draining their blood into the
coffin many lose more than enough blood
to result in death but none ever die
from this nor do they seem to feel any
pain from their wounds as the attendees
take turns bleeding into the coffin
cousin Johnny continues his eulogy which
eventually evolves into a cicada song
the kind sung by L's cicada males the
attendants sing the same song back to
him in a kind of call and response
cousin Johnny will then approach the
coffin and vomit in a mixture of blood
wood pulp and dead cicas the funeral
will then proceed as normal and the
blood vomit and cicada filed casket is
then taken to the cemetery and buried
Black Level events will usually end with
the body being interred in the ground
but if there's a wake after the funeral
the horrors of the Black Level event
will continue Contin you at the Wake
cousin Johnny will climb on top of a
table lie down and encourage the other
attendants to devour him which they do
all the while he continues to talk his
nonsense until there is nothing left
much like blue and white level events
being in attendance leads to horrific
After Effects all participants who
experience this event will separate from
their family through either suicide
moving or divorce every individual
present at the event will also find that
there are no longer able to produce
Offspring and coup's presence may also
fall victim to inciden sees of domestic
violence often involving cannibalism
that usually leave one or both
participants dead while six out of 10
children involved will attempt to murder
one or both of their parents before they
turn 18 these black level events are so
horrible for all involved that any
members of the specialized cousin Johnny
mobile task forces that happen to
witness such an event are treated with
class A amnestics before before they are
transferred to another task force or
retire to ensure that they don't have to
live with the memories of what they saw
prior to that they are closely monitored
for any strange or antisocial Behavior
to make sure they weren't affected by
the event and they aren't the only SCP
Foundation staff at risk of having been
impacted by cousin Johnny it is
theorized that as many as a third of
Catholic and Anglican d-class Personnel
were involved in a black level event at
some point and were driven to Madness
and violence by their fateful brushes
with the strange relative that no one
knows so next time you're at a baptism
or a wedding or a funeral stay vigilant
keep an eye on the other guests and
always ask yourself do you really have a
cousin Johnny it was the summer of 2012
in Damascus and for the people of Syria
it certainly seemed like all the
predictions about the end of the world
were coming true the Syrian Civil War
was raging between multiple Rebel groups
and the dictator Bashar al-assad whose
government was shelling its own people
as well as using chemical weapons and
brutal campaigns of violence across the
country in hopes of quelling the
Rebellion little did they know amidst
all this pain and bloodshed something
even more dangerous was brewing an
anomalous phenomenon in the sunny Plains
north of Damascus that may pose a threat
to all of humanity someday a threat
known to the SCP Foundation as SC PP
3989 the bone Orchard this temporal and
spatial anomaly was discovered a few
years earlier in 2009 before the Syrian
Civil War even officially began it's
strange for a highly dangerous cclass
anomaly to be discovered under such
seemingly mundane circumstances the SCP
Foundation first became aware of SCP
3989 after a small Olive Orchard owner
sold a strangely high amount of Olives
that shouldn't have been possible when
compared Ed to his reported number of OA
europea olive trees field agents were
dispatched to question the owner about
his sudden success but he was resistant
to questioning the agents began a covert
surveillance operation to figure out
what was actually going on here at which
point they discovered a considerable
spatial anomaly the olive Orchard was
Far bigger on the inside the property
was seized by the foundation for
containment the owner had no real
knowledge of the spatial anomaly it's
likely he just decided not to look a
gift horse in the mouth while making
money hand over fist from the extra
olives he sold the owner was given him
ncks and a new life as the foundation
began to study this anomaly which was
now labeled SCP
3989 to this day no researcher has been
able to figure out the origin of 3989
anomalous qualities it was first given a
uclid class designation and cordin off
from the public with a simple chain link
fence while Foundation investigations
were underway on the inside on a map the
plot of land the olive Farm should
occupy is about 5 square acres but this
plot contains an unseen portal to a
pocket Dimension within its 12 M active
Zone which doesn't follow the same
spatial laws that our reality does this
subdimension known as SCP
3989 is a hot bed of fascinating
anomalous activity upon discovery of
this Hot Zone the foundation established
the nearby area 126 as a research center
and a makeshift container facility for
any anomalous entities captured from SCP
3989 it seemed like the foundation
really had a handle on this situation
but they were blissfully unaware of the
true Horrors lurking with an SCP
3989 but they'd soon find out in the
most horrifying way possible Dr far
gazelli was assigned to head the
research into the anomalous Zone within
3989 and naturally he began organizing
fact finding Expeditions in Into the
Heart of the affected area the first
skinny pig to head into The Hot Zone was
former Foundation agent hosiah herck
who' been demoted to the lowly d-class
position of d126 D15 due to failures on
a previous Mission with a remote link to
Dr gazelli heric was forced to venture
into the active anomalous Zone to
collect footage and samples of the Flora
and Fauna within the first thing her
noticed on his expedition was the
strange quality of the olive trees
within the active Zone The Bark was a
stark white
and the leaves of bloody red up close
Herod could see that the Trunks and
branches of the trees had undergone a
process known as oifc where the material
slowly becomes bone or bone-like tissue
hence the anomaly's creepy name the bone
Orchard these aifi trees became known as
SCP
39891 heric also made another Discovery
all over the trees and ground were
wormlike creatures that looked like long
maggots that the foundation dubbed SCP
9-1a agent herck then noticed something
was off about the leaves of the aifi
trees they were beating he looked closer
and they appeared to be heart tissue
filled with pumping veins Dr gazelli
ordered herck to take a branch for
testing and when he did the tree began
to bleed when he looked down he saw that
the wormlike creatures that covered the
ground were now crawling up his legs
ignoring orders from Dr gazelli herck
fled from the active Zone in Terror as
he left Dr gazelli caught something in
the corner of herrick's body cam footage
a long white hind limb disappearing
behind a tree back in our normal
Dimension tests on the sample Hera
collected yielded more upsetting
discoveries genetically the trees were
identical to humans the trunks were
human bone and the leaves really were
made of human heart tissue fascinated
and just a little bit horrified Dr
gazelli authorized further Expeditions
into
3989 this time time though agent herck
would be accompanied by another d-class
and both would be armed with handguns
and protective body armor as it would
turn out this Expedition would be even
more horrifying than the first as the
two D classes explored the active zones
to collect further samples they found
that the worms were responsible for the
osificante noticed that these trees were
beginning to bear fruit Dr gazelli
ordered herck to collect some of this
fruit for testing but when they
attempted to remove the fruit it burst
releasing more worm creatures it seemed
that the converted trees acted as
incubators for their egg sacks before
the duo could return with the samples
they were able to take the creature that
had been spotted on herrick's body cam
during the first mission finally
appeared it was huge with long white
Limbs and no facial features EX except
for a huge mouth he grabbed herrick's
companion and literally ate the top half
of his body in a single bite before
dropping his legs to the ground this
horrifying Beast and the many others
like it would later be designated as SCP
3989 d2a herck pulled out his sidearm
and shot the creature several times the
creature ignored the bullets though and
charged her the feed from his body cam
cut out soon after both men were
declared killed in action and in
recognition of his sacrifice Josiah
herck was posthumously reinstated to his
old position in the foundation job well
done agent Dr gazelli meanwhile prepared
for the next mission this time knowing
of the clear dangers present within the
bone Orchard Dr gazelli recruited the
help of MTF Zeta 9 aka the mol rats
three members referred to as Charlie
team were sent into the anomalous Zone
once again remotely directed by Dr
gazelli they were equipped with
experimental Al ultrasound technology so
they could scan the fruit of the trees
within
3989 without breaking any and incurring
the wrath of 3989 d2a which seem to act
as centuries for the trees early on in
their Journey they found the body of
agent heric crucified against one of the
aifi trees his skin covered in
mysterious symbols that were likely of
saric origin well we don't have time to
fully explore sarcasm that will require
a video explanation all of its own all
you need to know is that it's a
dangerous religious cult that worships
flesh and disease and has close ties to
similar dangerous anomalies like SC SCP
610 also known as the flesh that hates
people familiar with that SCP will note
eerily strange similarities to some of
the things the mle rats were about to
encounter as Charlie team explored they
saw a huge number of 3989 2A observing
them with eyeless faces from between the
aifi trees they pressed on until they
discovered what seemed to be an entirely
new kind of tree within the bone Orchard
SCP 3989 D2 were huge trees made out of
what appears to be enlarged human spines
in place of a trunk the smaller Twigs on
the tree were made from heart and lung
tissue and the whole thing was covered
in what appeared to be human amniotic
Sachs Charlie team attempted to use
their ultrasound scanners to discover
the contents of these sacks but one of
them exploded in the process released
ing an entirely new variety of monster
from the Sachs emerged the larvel stage
of SCP 3989 d2b smaller humanoid
monsters with no faces No sensory organs
two pelvises four legs and an exposed
spine suddenly Charlie team could feel a
horrifying saric presence around them
which one member of the team described
as being like someone grabbing her liver
and giggling in her face as the various
Monsters of the bone Orchard began to
converge on the the team the voice of
the saric prophet of War and the hunt
Oro began sounding in their ears he was
beckoning them to join him while Charlie
team fled from the active Zone Dr
gazelli felt increasingly drawn into it
he heard the voice of Oro and he liked
what he heard little by little the
workers of area 126 were losing their
minds manipulated by the saric power of
the bone orchard right next to them day
after day they were no longer loyal to
the foundation they wanted to serve
their new Dark Masters the fourth and
final expedition was led by Dr gazeli
himself he took a band of loyal
followers and one non-believer on a
quest into the active Zone to find an
orchan Temple they believed was hidden
in the very heart of the bone Orchard
once they were inside gazeli and his
loyalists murdered the non-believer as a
sacrifice to their new master They
carried on until they eventually found
what they were looking for for a giant
Stone Temple resembling an Aztec zigurat
dubbed SCP 3989 D4 there they also
encountered a new kind of monster dubbed
SCP
39893 these beasts were larger than the
others and resembled ancient warriors
they had insect-like exoskeletal armor
horned heads additional Hind and for
liims and integrated bladed weapons what
Dr gazelli and his companions thought
would be paradise turned out to be a
kind of hell as they were led into the
temple where temporal and spatial
distortions broke their mind and the
multiple highly aggressive instances of
SCP
39893 d2a and -2b broke their bodies the
whole thing had been a horrifying trap
in that moment back at area 126 another
fleshy horrifying tree sprouted out of
the ground in the middle of the complex
monsters that had once been Dr gazelli
and his followers emerged from its
amniotic sacks and all hell broke loose
throughout the complex soon enough the
base was crawling with monsters from the
bone Orchard and staff who' become
brainwashed saric cultists working in
service of Oro humans were gathered up
to be sacrificed to the ever growing
number of anomalous trees things came to
a head when the anomaly in area 126 was
visited by an outside agent from the
foundation working on behalf of the
Hazardous Materials containment liaison
biological containment specialist Dr
Marshall Grant and his team arrived at
the site and were horrified to see the
saric nightmare that had unfolded they
quickly engaged in a firefight with the
anomalous creatures and saric devotees
who'd gained control over area 126 a
number of Dr Grant's team were lost in
the process but thankfully they were
able to eventually regain control of the
base and the anomalous area after this
incident SCP 3989 was upgraded to K
class and given a huge upgrade in
security including 4 M High concrete
walls and a platoon siiz Regiment of
mobile task force members with heavy
Weaponry the force that took over the
minds of those exposed was designated
SCP 3989 D5 a force so powerful that
those infected are given the choice to
self-terminate or be contained forever
this may seem like a somewhat happy
ending to a grim Tale But one detail
keeps Dr Grant and everyone at the
foundation who is forced to deal with
3989 awake at night according to all
recent studies into the bone Orchard it
isn't contained at all in fact the
active zone is getting bigger from
gigantic indestructible
self-regenerating reptiles to enormous
tentacle telepathic organisms it should
come as no surprise that the SCP
Foundation has gone head-to-head against
a lot of large scale aggressors or lsas
and it's time naturally a creature of
heightened size and aggression can often
prove challenging to contain and the
threat these lsas pose is often far too
big to ignore but anyone familiar with
the foundation will tell you they're not
above using any methods necessary to
keep these creatures contained huge Vats
of molecular acid impenetrable cells
disposable d-class Personnel even other
scps but what other scps could possibly
be big enough and Tough Enough
to handle some of the foundation's
biggest and baddest meet SCP
5514 otherwise known as the dragon
slayer well it might sound like
something out of an anime SCP 5514 is a
massive robotic Mech designed to take on
the worst other scps can throw at it for
any who are unfamiliar with the term a
Mech or Mecca usually refers to an
upright standing machine or automaton
controlled by a human pilot what
distinguishes is a Mech from a vehicle
is their often humanoid shape standing
by petal and they are often hundreds of
meters tall all of this is true of SCP
5514 and in fact given that it requires
a trained member of foundation staff to
operate it the mechad self requires very
little in the way of containment only
members of mobile task force ada5 are
trained and authorized to Pilot SCP
5514 this is one of the SCP Foundation
specialized units specifically designed
to deal with the threat of large scale
aggressors much like SCP 5514 itself but
SCP 5514 wasn't discovered or captured
by the foundation for use for the
containment of lsas nor was it stolen
from a foreign military or found buried
under the ground then where did it come
from and who built it working with the
global occult Coalition and the
government of high Brazil an anomalous
island off the west coast of Ireland the
foundation themselves constructed SCP
5514 using various anomalous methods and
techniques in 1988 a foundation site was
destroyed by an unidentified LSA
highlighting the inadequacy of the
current defenses against these larger
more damage resistant creatures the
foundation the Coalition and high Brazil
formed a joint operation the key project
and examined SCP
246 an automaton 93 m tall thought to be
created by ancient meanit
together the key project opted to create
their own similar machine viewing it as
the best way to defend against further
incursions with large scale aggressors
the construction of SCP 5514 began in
1990 the intention of all parties
involved in the key project including
the foundation was that the dragon
slayer would be deployed in the event of
an attack by an LSA it would arrive at
cities under attack and immediately
engaged large scale aggressors in combat
building of the mech continued at a
consistent pace for 8 years however it
was the occurrence of SCP
5391 and subsequent intervention by the
05 Council that accelerated the creation
of the Dragon Slayer by any means
necessary on June 30th 1998 a number of
seismic disturbances were detected
including tsunamis Tremors and volcanic
activity both underwater and above
ground What followed was the appearance
of multiple large scale aggressors which
would soon become designated as SCP
5391 the exact kind of scenario that the
dragon slayer was being built for had
already arrived and the mech was still
far from completion while the foundation
and its allies deployed forces to drive
the enormous creatures back to the ocean
something needed to be done to bring SCP
5514 into the fight and fast the 05
Council authorized the use of anomalous
materials in the continued construction
of the Dragon Slayer both to speed up
the process and have it ready for
deployment but also to give the mech
every advantage against the abundance of
large scale aggressors from SCP
5391 as a result SCP 5514 was designed
to incorporate features and Technology
far beyond that of any conventional
military grade weapons the first hurdle
how do you power a machine the size of
SCP
5514 naturally with the most gigantic
nuclear furnace there is the sun more
specific specifically a perpetually
stable miniaturized Sun known as SCP
037 even though it only has a diameter
of 2 in this little sucker is better
than premium fuel the surface
temperature of SCP 037 is around 5,000
kin generating plenty of energy to power
the SCP 5514 Mech stored in the dragon
slayer's chest this mini sun is kept
stable by subdimensional portals that
vent excess energy off this plane of
reality stopping the mech its pilot and
anything around it from melting in fact
SCP 037 produces so much juice that only
1% of its energy output is enough to
fully power SCP
5514 now that's the power source sorted
but how do you solve the weight problem
given the sheer size of SCP 5514 it
would be easy for it to be cumbersome
and potentially cause catastrophic
collateral damage to its surrounding
area well the Mex weight is a problem
for somewhere else a whole whole other
dimension in fact much like the excess
heat from its power source various heavy
portions of the SCP 5514 Mech have their
weight shunted off to a tiny pocket
Dimension it was ensured during the
creation of the mech that this
alteration was perfectly calculated so
that SCP 5514 wouldn't lose any mass or
density so it operates as if it were
only a fraction of its actual weight of
course being weightless makes flight a
whole lot easier oh did we forget to
mention that SCP 5514 can fly as well
this feature actually became a part of
the mech completely by accident during
the construction of SCP 5514 when an
attempt to regulate the mech's internal
circulation of air led to it having its
own gravity field this allowed SCP 5514
to fly without the aid of any turbines
or other means while this was an
unintentional mistake no attempt has
ever been made to correct for it for
fear that it could lead to SCP 5514
being grounded permanently naturally
going up against creatures so large that
they require their own subcategory means
that SCP 5514 needs an equally
formidable Arsenal so let's move on to
talk Weaponry mounted on the mech's
shoulder is a Beowolf sigur rail gun an
anomalous weapon that also doesn't obey
the laws of physics at all the Beowolf
sigard uses alternate gravity to affect
the weight of its targets causing
projectiles to impact with higher
velocity even the thickest skinned lsas
wouldn't want to be staring down the
barrel end of one of those big guns
aside the SCP 5514 Mech also wields a
cold iron sword over 65 ft long this
weapon was contributed to the Dragon
Slayer by the high Brazil Royal Court
members of the collaborative key project
that created the mech sure a large scale
aggressor with thicker hide might take a
few extra swings to draw blood but it
will feel those swings for a long time
after since any wounds in inflicted by
the cold iron sword will not regenerate
serving as less of an offensive weapon
the SCP 5514 Mech also features a unique
Armament known as the thousand-word
arrows as pretentious as it might sound
within the mech are seven poets their
role is to write and recite poems that
detail the slaying of monsters and these
recitals are then broadcast from the
dragon slay on the surface this seems to
have no practical applications during a
fight with lsas however ever the goal of
the thousand-word arrows is a form of
psychological warfare the recital of
poems telling of the mech Victory and
the defeat of large scale aggressors is
intended to have the effect of
demoralizing SCP 5514 adversaries while
encouraging the pilot during combat
additionally worn a top the head of the
SCP 5514 Mech almost like a hat is a
discus with plasma cated edges if the
dragon slayer needs to deal damage at
range then it can hurl this disc and
recall immediately thanks to built-in
electromagnets in emergency scenarios if
the cold iron sword is damaged or
dropped and irretrievable SCP 5514 is
also equipped with an additional melee
weapon stored in the right arm of the
mech is a holdout plasma wrist blade
this superheated blade is strong enough
to cut through almost anything however
this blade is strictly to be used as a
backup weapon finally should all else
fail one of SCP 5514 greatest strength
can also be used as a deadly weapon the
emergency Sun vent allows a fraction of
the Excess power from SCP 037 to be
released at the risk of causing massive
damage not only to lsas but to any
civilians or structures nearby it is
because of the destructive risk involved
that this weapon is only authorized to
be used as a final Resort and luckily
SCP 5514 is currently undefeated since
the arrival of multiple large- scale
aggressors as a result of SCP
5391 the SCP 5514 Mech has managed to
successfully eliminate 12 of these LSA
creatures either by terminating or
otherwise incapacitating them given that
its completion was fast-tracked through
the use of anomalous elements SCP 5514
first combat deployments also served as
field tests of the mech operation and
the various weapons and features
arriving in Tokyo overseen by the
foundation's own Captain Rosales and Dr
Kori SCP 5514 first Target was a
creature designated LSA wake 02 as well
as several other unidentified large
creatures as the LSA was about to attack
Tokyo Harbor SCP 5514 was dispatched
it's arrival heralded by the
thousand-word arrows champion champion
exalt in the glory of the Dragon Slayer
The Poets recited surprisingly The
Poetry worked hearing it had a
noticeable effect on LSA wake 02 causing
the creature to back away shrieking with
a single throw of the rounded recoiling
plasma SCP 5514 immediately beheaded
wake 02 damaging a number of the other
nearby lsas as it retrieved the disc via
its electromagnets once again the
thousand-word arrows cheered on the mech
in the pilot reciting the vicious Beast
slain gone to those which were once Bane
after dispatching several of the minor
lsas with its cold iron sword SCP 5514
became a aware that wake 02 was not
fully down for the count a second head
had protruded from the mouth of the
creatures first issuing some sort of
retreat call to the remaining lsas in
Tokyo Harbor this second head then shot
towards SCP 5514 narrowly missing its
leg but allowing other lsas to close the
distance and prepare an attack luckily
the SCP 5514 Mech sword cleaved the
beast in two the mech began firing on
the remains of wake 02 with its Bale
wolf cured rail gun launch ing itself
into the air and flying towards the
target while bringing its cold iron
sword down through the air with a single
motion SCP 5514 brought the blade all
the way down the lsa's body from the
creature's head to its coddle fin
gutting the large scale aggressor and
splitting its entire body in two after
one final squirm both halves were
finally still SCP 5514 had passed its
first field test the mech functioned
exactly as has designed all its various
weapons and features working in tandem
to defeat a creature far too large and
Powerful for any conventional Force to
handle and thus the deed was done exalt
exalt in the glory of the Dragon Slayer
the thousand-word arrows called out as
the other lsas retreated one cannot help
but feel cautiously optimistic about our
chances of survival knowing that the
foundation as SCP 5514 as the first line
of defense against huge monstrous beings
that threaten Humanity as the situation
with SCP 5391 continues the SCP 5514
Mech remains on the front line standing
between innocent human beings and the
looming shapes of multiple large scale
aggressors with creatures that pose such
a large scale threat it certainly is
lucky that disperate groups were able to
put aside their differences and work
together to build a large scale Mech and
because they did now we have the dragon
slayer on our side Ranger halter felt
the bark of the tree trunk slamming into
his back practically knocking all the
air out of his lungs as he tried
desperately to slow his frantic
breathing the sound of his own panting
filled him with a sudden horrifying
thought if he could hear his own ragged
breaths then it could hear them too he
clamped a hand over his mouth clenching
his jaw shut so tightly that he thought
his teeth might Splinter as he pushed
them together his free hand grip the
tranquilizer gun shuttering as the snap
of a twig rang out somewhere behind him
it had caught up to him already he could
bolt make a quick dash for a cover
behind another tree but it was close
enough now that it would see him and if
it did it would come rushing after him
with a speed that even a season park
ranger couldn't match as much as he
tried to force himself to stay still the
Petrified curiosity got the better of
him halter peaked out from behind the
tree and immediately wished he hadn't it
had all started out as what sounded like
an everyday occurrence high at top his
watchtower in the Glacier National Park
Ranger halter had been enjoying the view
of Montana's Rocky Mountains a cup of
coffee from his thermos in his hand then
the familiar squawk of His Radio had cut
short his appreciation of the Serene
scenery halter side tossing the
remaining contents of the cup over the
tower's railing wondering what kind of
day he was in for as he went to answer
the radio
most of the time things in Glacier Park
were as peaceful as they looked but the
park ranger knew that staying Vigilant
could make all the difference when it
came to finding a missing hiker in time
or the difference between deterring a
group of campers away from a family of
bears and having a hell of a mess to
clean up he pushed down on the button
for the microphone connected to the
bulky radio that took up practically an
entire desk halter thank God came the
relieved voice from the other side we've
been trying to reach everyone put them
on alert we've got trouble reports of a
coyote gone feral attacking folks I'm on
it halter replied grabbing his gear from
the cramped Watchtower as he continued
to speak into the mic where did the
report come in from not far from your
station I'd say about a click West from
your position stowing his tranquilizer
gun Ranger holder descended the ladder
from his Watchtower down to ground level
as a park ranger holder valued the
environment he worked in and as a fan of
the SCP Universe we know how much you
value intricate World building or in
some cases World destroying but either
way we couldn't be happier to introduce
you to the sponsor of today's video
World Anvil World Anvil is a
comprehensive set of World building
tools that not only help you craft and
organize your unique setting but also
present it in a captivating manner from
wik likee articles and interactive maps
to a full-fledged RPG campaign manager
and novel writing software World Anvil
has everything a World creator could
dream of world Anvil equips you with
over 25 templates prompting you to dive
deeper into your Creations enrich your
content by embedding math apps images
sound effects and even little secrets
for that immersive touch with their
Innovative design you can easily
visualize your world through Maps
Chronicle its history with timelines and
fine-tune events with intricate details
your crafted world can be beautifully
showcased on a unique homage inviting
others to dive into your vision got a
sudden idea while working on another no
problem World Anvil lets you swiftly
create new articles or link existing
ones ensuring you never lose track of
your inspiration but my personal
favorite feature is their interactive
maps Beyond just creating and uploading
your own designs you can directly link
your Creations allowing for a dynamic
and engaging experience and if you're
collaborating invite your team to refine
write and even let your fans chip in I'm
currently working on my own interactive
map of site 17 and maybe I'll even let
you see it when I'm done but don't wait
for me dive into World Anvil yourself
and elevate your world building game and
here's a treat use our Link in the
description to go to worldanvil tocom
and use the code SCP to grab a a
whopping 51% off any yearly subscription
explore create and share with World
Anvil the sun was already starting to
dip out of sight behind the trees pretty
soon it'd be pitch black save for the
beam of his flashlight he had to move
fast coyotes were only known to attack
humans on rare occasions usually they
kept away at least enough to make them a
minimal risk but waiting for him just
west of the Watchtower wasn't a coyote
at least not at first watching it from
behind the tree moments later Ranger
Halter's stomach turned at the sight of
the creature it walked bipedally like a
human but the shape was all wrong its
legs looked broken but that hadn't
stopped it from catching up instead of
bending at the knee they were z-shaped
pointing back behind the creature then
twisting back again in the opposite
direction at the Joint they looked more
like the legs of a dog but they were far
too big the same could be said of the
arms bent out of shape at multiple
points like its length were the creature
was a mess of misshapen limbs the
cartilage and its ears had seemingly
reformed into points and there were
claws protruding from its fingertips
practically bursting out from where a
human's fingernails would be but beneath
it all and what alarmed Ranger halter
the most was its skin it had darkened in
patches layers of fur sprouting over
those areas but there were still parts
that remained clear where skin human
skin was still visible peeling way to
reveal the new fur coated layer
underneath it looked like a grotesque
accident like something ripped straight
out of an old horror movie the kind of
monster that a mad scientist would make
by halfhazard Le splicing DNA and
playing God hter checked the
tranquilizer gun in his trembling
fingers still empty after that most
recent shot he reached for another Dart
slowly sliding it into the loading
mechanism and readying the pistol it
cocked and made a sound the creature's
malformed head turned turned snapping
directly towards the source of the noise
directly towards halter he turned to
Sprint away trying to expand the
distance between him and it if he was
too close the dart wouldn't have enough
momentum when he pulled the trigger the
toe of his boot snagged on something
solid unmoving a root from the tree he'd
been hiding behind he felt himself
tumble Landing with a hard thud against
the forest floor his gun it had fallen
from his grasp he scrabbled around in
the dirt for it barely able to see where
the tranquilizer had landed in the dark
just as his fingertips brush past
something metal hter felt the force of
something heavy strike his back again
this time though it wasn't a tree it was
the creature it snarled nashing its
canned Jaws that were protruding out of
its skull rows of sharp teeth that had
uprooted the old ones bearing themselves
into the park ranger's neck and not
letting go until he'd stopped moving for
good a few short hours later a convoy of
mysterious unmarked Vehicles arrived at
AER National Park the rest of the park
rangers who had reported the strange
activity were approached by shadowy
figures who refused to give their names
or offer up any form of identification
other than just referring to themselves
as experts in things like this not long
after none of the others would remember
Ranger halter or the incident that had
led to his untimely death after
administering amnestics it didn't take
the SCP Foundation search party long to
discover a lone coyote sniffing around
the remains of a park range covered in
blood the wild animal was captured to be
brought back for testing before being
re-released into the wild meanwhile the
foundation scoured the rest of the area
until they came across the real culprit
standing in a clearing a short distance
from a foot path through the forest was
SCP
1579 of course the next challenge was
getting it packed up and transported to
biosite 66 without touching it to the
untrained I SCP 1579 looks to be fairly
unassuming even as far as anomalous
objects go it is simply an old wooden
sculpture the kind that can even be
occasionally found in various wooded
areas throughout the world its age is
Apparent from even one cursory glance at
SCP 1579 the partial damage to its Cedar
surface speaking to the numerous years
it has existed for along with the bright
green moss that covers it although
curiously this Moss doesn't seem to dry
out and die in responses to changes in
human humidity nor does it affect SCP
1579 structural Integrity as for where
it came from and who made it those are
still unknown as if the answer to what
holds SCP 1579 anomalous properties
whether or not the cedar it was carved
from or the Moss coating the sculpture
possesses some unknown Properties or if
SCP 1579 was somehow imbued with these
after being created initial testing by
the SCP foundation's researchers
determined as CP 1579 to have an
abnormally high resistance to the type
of damage wood and particularly cedar
wood is susceptible to for one it does
not seem to show any signs of rotting or
natural degradation for another it is
also resistant to heat at least to a
certain extent it doesn't burn the same
way other objects constructed from
Cedarwood however this sculpture is not
entirely indestructible pieces can be
easily chipped off of the main body of
SCP 1579
and these splintered fragments continue
to carry the same anomalous effects as
the rest of the sculpture even when
separate from it but of course you want
to know about the creature how does this
supposedly harmless if a little
structurally abnormal Cedarwood
sculpture connects to whatever it was
that killed park ranger halter well it's
quite simple actually SCP 1579 killed
halter not directly you understand but
by proxy through its further anomaly
properties still confused well then how
about a demonstration let's take a look
at one of the foundation's preferred
test subjects an Expendable member of
d-class personnel probably spending
multiple life sentences working here at
the SCP Foundation rather than behind
the bars of a maximum security
institution now what would happen if you
place this delightful individual in the
same room as SCP
1579 well nothing initially that is
until until the subject touches the
cedar wood surface of the sculpture
either out of curiosity or following the
instructions of a foundation researcher
that's when the real anomaly starts the
wooden sculpture will exhibit a slight
but observable movement shuttering
slightly as if moved by an unseen Force
this will precede the person who touched
the object feeling a burning sensation
that kind of irritating painful heat
that spreads underneath the surface of
the skin the burning will always begin
at the area of their body that made
direct contact with SCP
1579 and touching it again at any point
will trigger a reactivation of the
sculptures anomalous effects subjects
experiencing the effects of SCP 1579
have described the feeling as being akin
to a bad sunburn that rapidly spreads
Across the Skin from the point of
contact only to stop once it has
affected a person's entire body
following the subsidence of the burning
sensation subjects experiencing the side
effects of touching a CP 1579 will
notice an immediate change to Their Skin
Within a window of 3 minutes their skin
becomes thin and paper-like in its
texture before starting to peel away
once this stage occurs the peeling skin
will reveal a new layer underneath hence
the colloquially used code name for this
anomaly different skin however the
so-called different skin isn't merely a
new layer of otherwise ordinary human
skin instead it will belong to another
species entirely a person coming into
contact with SCP 1579 will find
themselves rapidly developing new skin
that shares the physical traits as well
as matching DNA to that of a number of
animal species it should be noted that
these features will continue to rapidly
develop until the subject is entirely
transformed and is no longer considered
to qualify as a human being as for the
specific transformation that occurs
there are a number of known outcomes
that repeat in the following cycle let's
say our declass we'll call them subject
a touched as CP 1579 at the start of the
cycle they would after the burning
sensation stops and peeling begins start
to sprout dark feathers across their
torso arms and upper legs likely with a
great deal of pain as the sharp Quill of
these feathers start to burst out from
beneath the skin beneath the knees
subject a will see their legs start to
become yellow and scaly as well as a
change that causes their toenails to
Simply start to painfully protrude
outward until they form pointed
blackened Talons subject A's face will
also start to grow feathers however
these grow outwards away from the areas
of the nose and mouth flight feathers
will also protrude from the forearms
multiplying in number until their entire
body is covered at which point subject a
on every level including genetically
more closely resembles a corvis korax
more commonly known as the common raven
than a human being anymore take another
test subject subject B and get them to
touch SCP 1579 right after their
different skin is covered in brown fur
that's approximately 4 in Long their
lips and skin underneath the fur will
darken and their nose will become
constantly moist claws will start to
grow from their fingertips although
these will be notably smaller than those
of a fully grown creature of the same
species an ursus arctos horribilis or a
grizzly bear then we get to the point in
the cycle where some unwitting hiker
encountered SCP 1579 in the forests of
Glacier National Park Montana when this
subject subject C touched the cedar
sculpture their skin began to grow
layered fur as the cartilage of their
ears is separated from their tissue and
replaced by new reshaped cartilage much
like subject B who SCP 1579 turned into
a grizzly bear subject C also had
darkened skin a moistened nose and
longer sharper Nails it was at some
point during this transformation that an
unassuming park ranger stumbled upon
subject C frightened by what he saw this
Ranger was unable to identify that what
he interpreted as attacks by some kind
of half human half animal hybrid were
actually desperate pleas for help as
subject C was transformed into a coyote
although it's hard to say which
physiological change triggered by a CP
1579 is the most alarming or unpleasant
to experience The Fourth Kind is in no
way any more pleasant than the preceding
three three in the cycle subject D of
this particular series of tests will
find the new layer of skin that emerges
under the old to be hairless and of a
green coloration often with brown
markings unlike the previous instances
their skin will rapidly begin to dry out
and seems to be far more reactive to the
humidity of the surrounding environment
it is also far thinner than that of the
skin possessed by other Transformations
that SC SCP 1579 causes so thin in fact
that the eyeballs of subject D will be
visible through its eyelids which
rapidly become translucent similar to
those of the suris regula otherwise
known as the Pacific Tree Frog repeated
activation of SCP 1579 anomalous
properties will trigger the next
transformation in the cycle whether the
Cedarwood sculpture is touched by a new
subject or repeatedly by the same person
in the latter instance where a subject
is reexposed to SCP 1579 the additional
changes their body undergos will be
significantly more painful their already
newly replaced outer layer of skin will
fail to dry out and will begin bleeding
instead three or four consecutive
exposures to SCP 1579 will lead to
excessive bodily trauma for the subject
usually causing them to die from shock
before the fourth transformation is
complete and as we're sure you can
imagine an amalgamation of a human a
raven a grizzly bear a coyote and a tree
frog is hardly a pleasant sight this
unfortunate fate was suffered during one
of the first incidents with SCP 1579
that brought the foundation's attention
to it during an elementary school field
trip a teacher who was explaining the
history of totem poles in Native
American culture accidentally touched
SCP
1579 while experiencing the pain of her
transformation she fell against the
sculpture in a panic not realizing it
had been what caused her to change this
repeated triggering of the object's
anomalous effects led to her untimely
death an event that had to be wiped from
the minds of her students by the
foundation using the careful application
of Class B amnestics for now SCP 1579 is
kept in a secure sterile environment at
a foundation storage Warehouse where
Personnel are not permitted to make any
contact with it so there's no need to
worry about accidentally running into
SCP 1579 in the wild although there are
always plenty of other things to worry
about while out on a hike through the
forest things that could be right behind
you a giant monstrous craik claw closes
around the throat of an unimaginably
huge eel-like Beast the beast's terrible
writhing tentacles wrap around and latch
onto the immense crustation and then the
high-intensity beams of gamma radiation
start flying all the while Legions of
skinless centaurs swim in the waters
around them relishing the violence and
in the middle a lone boat the scps
mither manned by a team of mobile task
force operatives that does all it can
just to survive there are those who
consider outer space to be the ultimate
achievement in Exploration the one place
that explorers have yet to chart and
understand however some of the murkiest
Mysteries in the universe are on our own
Planet deep down at the bottom of the
ocean 95% of the deep ocean remains
completely unexplored and the little
glimpses we have gotten paint a picture
of something truly alien
giant squids organisms that can breathe
nitrogen luminescent predatory fish and
sharks as old as the Earth itself even
the SCP Foundation is still struggling
to fully grasp the depth of the ocean
and the strange beings that dwell there
one of the most unusual aquatic findings
in the history of the foundation is that
of SCP
3700 SCP 3700 refers to a circular area
in the North sea with a diameter of 800
km the waters there are abnormally deep
for the region with the seafloor resting
at 5 km beneath the ocean's surface
there are two entities present in the
waters of SCP 3700 designated SCP
37001 and SCP
37002 interactions between these two
entities are responsible for the
anomalous changes to the meteorological
and geological conditions in the area as
CP
37001 and SCP
37002 always interact on the spring and
fall equinoxes of Any Given year but
they will also engage one another
throughout the year seemingly at random
but what exactly are SCP
37001 and SCP
37002 aside from terrifying creatures of
the deep SCP 37001 is an arthropod
bearing an aesthetic resemblance to the
European Lobster only much much bigger
measuring 6 km in length the creature is
green with a mix of blue yellow pink and
red markings across the top of its
exoskeleton that bear the appearance of
a woman's face it has six prehensile
limbs four of which terminate in Claws
and eight legs the entities four eyes
are compound and orange attached to
stalks anyone who gets close enough to
observe the creatures car Pace in detail
will notice scars cracks and small holes
indicating years and years of damage SC
SCP 37001 has several anomalous
qualities in addition to its size in a
fight it is able to strike with its
appendages and produce cavitation
bubbles with a force greater than
several tons of Dynamite two of the
entities eyes are capable of blasting
concentrated gamma radiation at a chosen
Target the creature has the ability to
impact the weather around it dispersing
storms that impede its ability to move
with ease and can reach speeds up to 100
km an hour in spite of its immense power
SCP
37001 is not aggressive and tends to
ignore beings in its vicinity other than
SCP 3700 D2 speaking of SCP
37002 it is a 32 km long entity
resembling a pelican eel in all aspects
except for its massive size and the 13
appendages that encircle the middle
section of its body these appendages
which tuck inside its body when not in
use are similar to the tentacles of an
octopus complete with suckers the
majority of the entity's body consists
of a senu tail terminating in a sharp
point when its mouth is open it is an
estimated 3 km deep its flesh is black
and it has white purple and red
bioluminescent lines in the shape of a
man's face on either side of its torso
SCP 3700 d2's anomalous properties
include the ability to invoke storms
with the severity of category 5
hurricanes and the ability to produce
whirlpools that draw in any vessel
within 150 M so that it can rip them
apart it is also able to produce high
energy sound waves as well as blue fire
which it emits from its esophagus when
the two entities interact it results in
an epic struggle as each begins attempts
to destroy or subdue the other when one
is Victorious immediate changes to the
area follow when SCP 37001 wins the
storms and harsh weather in the area
will immediately calm and an era of
fertility and abundance will begin the
reproductive rates of fauna in the ocean
and on the Islands nearby increase
threefold and the crop yield doubles the
ocean itself itself becomes increasingly
active and the erosion rates of the
archipelago's shores increase fivefold
when SCP 3 700-2 winds however the
weather conditions become dangerous with
raging hurricanes rapidly fluctuating
temperatures and constantly changing
Storm fronts that cause destruction of
buildings and loss of life naturally
this renders any Ocean Travel in the
area extremely difficult or even
impossible aquatic food sources are driv
driven Away by harsh conditions and
livestock are killed by exposure and
disease crops are unable to thrive in
the high winds water logs soil and lack
of sunlight all the while SCP 37002
swims throughout the area praying on
unsuspecting ships and menacing the
coastline until SCP 37001 manifests to
challenge it again SCP
37002 will also regurgitate instances is
of SCP
3456 though how or why this is possible
is unknown for those unfamiliar with SCP
3456 they are a group of hairless three-
toed horike creatures with thick
translucent skin and human torsos fused
to their backs they are most frequently
seen near sights of War terrorist
attacks and devastating natural
disasters direct observation of one of
these entities will draw their attention
to the Observer who the entity will then
stalk and capture before disappearing
due to their enormous size and ability
to anomalously manifest in their home
Waters SCP
37001 and 2 cannot be contained at a
foundation site instead their
containment is handled by Foundation
Naval task force Delta 7 Northern Storm
who Patrol the area in combination of
refurbished battleships destroyers
Cruisers and support craft additionally
measures have been taken taken to
suppress information about SCP 3700
among the general population details
about the unusual depth of the waters
there have been stricken from public
texts and scientific Publications SCP
37001 has been implanted with donovian
Hollow projectors which disguise it as a
pod of humpback whales if SCP 37001
encounters SCP
37002 Delta 7 May engage protocol winter
m
this consists of Destroyers deploying
Harpoon based anchors into SCP 3700 d2's
head to hold it in one location next the
vessels work together to Target The
Entity until SCP 37001 is able to subdue
it if this does not prove effective and
SCP
37002 cannot be contained then the task
force will Implement protocol tumult at
this point Naval and civilian crafts in
the area must be evacuated TR ra and
Ferry routes to the archipelagos must be
rerouted for at least 6 months there
will be constant aerial and Naval
engagement with SCP
37002 and constant monitoring for the
reappearance of SCP
37001 the behavior of SCP 37001 and SCP
37002 is largely very predictable with
one notable exception on March 20th 2017
a pair of SCP Foundation owned
battleships known as the mither and the
Teran arrived at a point between the
orne Shetland and Pharaoh archipelagos
in the North Sea they were accompanied
by the usual Fleet of Delta 7 ships
approximately 600 M away from the ship's
anchor points the water began to emit
intense bright rays of light for a
duration of 3 minutes at this point SCP
37001 appeared visible through the
surface of the water Delta 7 withdrew
their anchors speeding toward the entity
as the ships caught up to The Entity it
raised two of its claws into the air
clicking them together in a friendly
greeting the Delta 7 ships followed the
entity along its usual swimming path for
30 minutes and during this time all was
peaceful but this peace did not endure
for long the tide began to change
literally as large black wall clouds
formed overhead the winds picked up and
the waves churned violently in response
as SCP 37001 raised its claws overhead
head waving them in a circular motion
and parting the clouds above it and
Delta 7 but this effort took a lot out
of the creature and after 30 seconds its
antenna began to droop and it lowered
its claws still the hole in the clouds
remained allowing a spot of sunshine to
break through and beam down on the
foundation vessels 600 M ahead the ocean
waters began to rage and froth spraying
foam and surf into the air SCP 3700 Dash
tube burst from beneath the surface its
head pointed upward it continued to rise
until the tops of its tentacles could be
seen just above the water then stopped
to bend its torso and turn its head
horizontally its jaw unhinged exposing
rows upon rows of serrated teeth the
Beast let out a mighty Roar accompanied
by a stream of blue flame at the sight
of its rival SCP 37001 Dove beneath the
surface disappearing from View the scps
mither ordered the rest of the vessels
to engage protocol winter Maelstrom
Delta 7 scattered out from SCP 3700 d1's
point of submersion and all 13
destroyers fired their harpoons at SCP
37002 embedding themselves in the
entity's head naturally this enraged the
creature and it began to Roar and whale
spinning its lower body vigorously
enough to generate a Whirlpool the
Cruisers opened fire with a combination
of L cannons and conventional Weaponry
in order to distract The Entity as the
Destroyers pulled their Harpoon lines
taut dragging its head in a continuous
Circle while this was taking place the
battleships got into position and
prepared to fire on the mither's Mark 3
2 1 fire the first broadside barrage
collided with SCP
37002 and it grunted in pain thrashing
back and forth before opening its mouth
and spewing an instance of SCP 3 456
into the water as soon as it hit the
water the eoin monster began to cut
through at a pace of 50 km an hour
making its way toward the Destroyers
particularly the scps selki the skki
attempted to retarget its weapons and
prevent the creature from reaching it
but the monster moved too quickly for
the skki to adjust the skki was lifted
out of the water by the creature as crew
members desperately clung to the
railings and their Weaponry as the crew
cowered and tried to fend off the
creature it reach for them trying to
pull them from the ship while the sky
was occupied SCP 3700 D2 was able to
attack again blasting another ship with
a stream of blue fire a loud crack rang
out from across the sea as the sky
dropped back into the water the SCP 3456
instant shrieking in pain SCP 3700 D1
burst through the surface striking the
creature with its Club likee limbs each
blow emitting another loud crack the
third blow tore the instance in half
sending its human torso careening
through the air and past the scps mither
freed from its attack the skki moved
full steam ahead pulling the Harpoon
line TD again and dragging SCP 3700 D2
out of its path several silky crew
members were thrown overboard during the
struggle and as they struggled to keep
their heads above water ascp 37001
scooped them up placing them onto the
deck of a nearby destroyer and out of
out of Harm's Way with the crew members
rescued SCP 3700 D1 set its sights on
its enemy swimming towards the edge of
the whirlpool and emitting a luminescent
glow from two of its eyes the constant
barrage of cannon fire on SCP 37002 was
beginning to take its toll and the
myther ordered the fleet to quote brace
for the killing blow as if responding to
the mither's call SCP 37001 shot several
concentrated blasts of gamma radiation
at its foe leaving large holes in the
creature in their wake SCP 37002
screamed flailing so hard that it
snapped the Harpoon lines and created
waves large enough to push the vessels
backward with its new found Freedom SCP
3700 D2 impaled SCP 37001 through the
midsection with its Barbed tip of its
tail lifting it up and out of the water
with the force of the blow SCP 37001
desperately tried to free itself
attacking the tail with its Club likee
limbs but the fight was in vain and
after a moment all movement stopped SCP
37001 was for at least the duration of
this manifestation dead SCP 37002 tossed
the corps into the water flinging it
past Delta 7 where it crashed into the
water and sank down Into the Depths
below at this point Delta 7 was ordered
to initiate protocol tumult the Delta 7
vessels turned away from SCP 3700 -2 and
prepared to evacuate the area one of the
ships the scps Str Beast slowed behind
the rest of the fleet emitting
concerning amounts of smoke before
coming to a stop meanwhile the enraged
and emboldened SCP
37-2 expanded the size of its Whirlpool
setting its sights on the retreating
ships and the weakened strawy Beast the
ship tried to flee but the engines were
completely shot and would not respond
the ship was caught in the whirlpool and
pulled against its will toward SCP 3700
D2 as the crew looked on in helpless
dread a tentacle Rose from the deep
wrapping around the vessel and dragging
it toward the entity escaping Mall
suddenly SCP 37001 exploded from beneath
the surface of the water leaping between
the ship and SCP
37002 cutting the tentacle in half and
freeing the sty beast from its grip SCP
37002 shrieked before closing its jaws
and biting down on SCP
37001 it retaliated emitting bright
flashes of light and doing enough damage
to stop SCP 3700 D2 from continuing to
produce its Whirlpool another tentacle
emerged from the water pulling at SCP
3700 d1's legs and ripping them from its
body but SCP 37001 returned the assault
in kind bludgeoning SCP 37002 with its
Club likee limbs from inside of its
mouth all at once SCP 3700 d2's lower
jaw was torn out of place dropping into
the water with SCP 3700 D1 still inside
SCP 3700 D2 thrashed fuly growing
steadily weaker and weaker it released
one more stream of fire before
collapsing Delta 7 paused The Retreat
watching the scene for any sign of a
winner but after 5 minutes neither
entity had moved Delta 7 returned to the
side of the battle to investigate and
saw that neither entity was moving and
both appeared to be deceased shortly
after Delta 7 reached the area both
entities disappeared leaving a single
round unidentified object that sank
below the surface where SCP
3700-3 uh this is Delta 7 to command we
read you Delta 7 command replied we have
a bit of a situation go ahead Delta 7
SCP
37001 and two are both down command was
silent for 10 seconds utterly baffled by
the information please repeat Delta 7
again the myther said SCP
37001 and 2 are both down command
ordered the myther to standby 3 minutes
of radio silence later communication
resumed as they asked are either
entities's effects active ah negative
command is there any trace of either
entity also negative it appears the
anomaly has been neutralized Delta 7 is
to return to base for debrief following
any recovery efforts with their next
steps clear Delta 7 attached the strawy
bees to several tugboats preparing to
pull the vessel to safety but there was
one more surprise waiting the scps
mither began picking up unusual level of
gamma radiation as well as a sonar
contact at a depth of 3 km they called
command requesting permission to deploy
submersibles for exploration purposes
one minute of Silence followed as the
command arrived at a decision request
denied return to base for debriefing and
so Delta 7 began to evacuate the area
once more steaming in the opposite
direction of the battle over the next 5
minutes CCTV cameras on the vessels
picked up an unusual sight as the Gam
radiation levels continued to increase
the ocean turbulence also worsened
tossing smaller vessels and nearly
causing them to capsize then all of a
sudden the water stilled and four large
yellow orbs appeared below the surface
approximately 300 M from Delta 7 they
lingered there for 2 minutes before
Vanishing afterward a new sonar contact
was detected 5 km deep directly beneath
the task force command we've lost the
signal from the previous is contact and
are no longer detecting gamma radiation
uh we're detecting new contact 5 km deep
large and metallic after further
deliberation command responded Delta 7
you are authorized to deploy
submersibles for exploration purposes be
advised should SCP 37002 manifest
exploration teams are to be considered
lost and you are to return to base the
consequences of this incident as well as
what else might be lurking down in the
depths beneath SCP 3700 are still
unknown Maria Delgado tumbled through
the air the Furious sea wind whipped all
around her her hair blew in her eyes
trying to Shield them from the view of
what was rapidly coming to hit her
Square in the face an ocean as black as
the night sky she barely had a second to
brace herself before splash the impact
in the cold knocked all the air out of
her a flurry of bubbles disappeared into
the darkness as she sank further and
further further down not knowing which
way was up Maria kicked frantically as
her water logged clothes dragged her
back her head found the surface and she
barely had a moment to gasp in half a
lung full of air before a wave hit her
in the side of the head knocking her
back under kicking and spluttering she
managed to poke her head up again and
tried to wave desperately at the metal
Behemoth looming over her the cruise
ship that had felt so safe and warm now
looked like a cliff face the lowest
window that she could see was more than
100 ft above her head there had been
music playing on the deck but she was so
far below now that she couldn't even
hear it anymore all she could hear was
the rumbling of the engines and an
ominous swishing chopping sound behind
her Maria's stomach dropped she felt the
ocean pulling at her a current forcing
her beneath the waves she had fallen off
the back of the cruise ship and that
meant the current gripping her and
turning her beneath the water she
tumbled and twisted in the darkness
feeling all of the air rushing out of
her lungs again squinting as best as she
could through the stinging saltwater she
saw the thing that she'd been dreading
an enormous propeller each Blade the
size of her house spinning and spinning
just on the edge of her vision and
gliding steadily towards her the water
was sucking her towards it pulling her
faster and faster she'd never been a
very strong swimmer but there wasn't
time to feel bad about that now she
needed to escape any way she could
desperately lashing at the water Maria
kicked and clawed herself out of the
current she had to swim sideways as fast
as she could otherwise she didn't want
to think about it the propellers were
getting closer getting larger in the
water the awful sound of their approach
didn't just shake the water around her
it shook all of the water inside of her
making her stomach turn in fear she
hadn't breathed in in a long time her
body was going into shock from the cold
everything everything around her was
doing its best to drag her down to a
slow icy death or maybe a fast painful
death from the impact of several tons of
spinning steel something hard and fast
crunched into Maria's heel moving so
quickly that it sent her spinning
through the water the propeller had hit
her its next Revolution passed about a
foot in front of her face before the
turbulence of the cruise ship's wake
took hold of her and threw her away then
all of a sudden fresh air was hitting
her face the water had lifted her up to
the surface and carried her in the foamy
wake that stretched away from the cruise
ship already the metal Juggernaut was a
couple of hundred feet away from her if
she tried to swim after it the currents
in the water would only carry her
further backward Maria had no choice but
to tread water and stare as the cruise
ship that had once been so large and
imposing above her steadily became a DOT
on the horizon and then disappeared
entirely her husband had been in bed she
had just stepped out onto the deck to
have have some fresh air he could sleep
through anything chances are he wouldn't
notice she was missing until he woke up
in the morning and who knew what time
that would be they were on vacation and
he hadn't set an alarm he would probably
assume that she'd gone for an early
breakfast without him only once he'd sat
down and finished his breakfast and gone
back to the room to find she was still
missing would he start to worry by that
point she would have stopped kicking
hours ago she wasn't sure how deep the
ocean was out here how many minutes
would it take for her body to sink to
the bottom or would it take hours
perhaps her corpse wouldn't even be
halfway down to the seabed by that point
she was shivering so violently that she
was struggling to keep herself above the
surface her legs weren't kicking like
they would in a pool they were spasming
and tensing up her clothes ballooned all
around her doing nothing but get in the
way as she tried desperately to stay
alive she had no phone it had fallen off
the deck with her now likely on its own
way down to the seafloor she had had no
light not enough air in her lungs to cry
for help and no one between herself and
the Horizon to hear this was it this was
how she would die a sense of morbid
curiosity filled her what exactly was
below her maybe there was a reef
somewhere down where her corpse could
lie peacefully what she saw when she
stuck her head beneath the surface was
Darkness swirling and empty and
painfully cold except there was
something else moving down there it
looked small smaller than she was some
kind of sea creature swimming up to meet
her Maria lifted her head took a deep
breath and swam down towards it it
wasn't swimming like a usual fish its
shadowy silhouette seemed to Ripple and
twist as her eyes slowly adjusted to the
darkness she saw what it was a squid
maybe a meter in length at least she
wouldn't be dying alone out here the
squid started to swim faster approaching
her quickly at that moment she suddenly
remembered some of the things she had
heard about squids weren't they Hunters
she had seen a nature documentary once
where sperm whales had come up from the
seabed with enormous gouges around their
eyes from where they'd been attacked by
a school of squids suddenly Maria didn't
want her companion anymore but it was
too late the squid had almost reached
her end she felt her mind starting to
float out of itself her eyes weren't
focusing properly the squid wasn't just
swimming towards her it was flashing
almost like a strob light different lurd
colors filled the ocean around her and
it convulsed in different colors until
all of a sudden it wasn't a small squid
at all anymore it ballooned in size
swelling and bulging all around her
enormous tentacles unfurled themselves
and whipped at the water all around her
it was 10 m tall now 20 40 70 the squid
seemed to fill the whole ocean
swallowing up all of the available water
and leaving her in a tiny puddle
floating just a few feet away from its
gashing beak some of the tentacles
didn't even look like tentacles anymore
they had turned into Pinchers or even
human looking arms and legs except the
fingers were tipped with grotesque
Talons she had to escape had to get away
if Maria had thought she'd swam fast to
get away from the cruise ship's
propellers it was nothing compared to
how fast she swam now without care for
her trembling limbs struggling lungs or
rapidly fading Consciousness Maria knew
she had to get away from this
monstrosity there was no hope for her
without escape the flashing lights felt
like they were all around her no matter
which way she swam it just felt like
they were getting brighter and brighter
until a pair of hands grabbed her and
lifted her out of the water Maria kicked
and screamed trying to fight the
tentacles off but they pinned her down
to the deck and held her there voices
surrounded her bright lights shining in
her face this was how she would die
until a shadow blocked out one of the
lights and her eyes made managed to
focus on something it was a man he was
talking to her in another language
desperately trying to calm her down
where was the squid what had happened to
it Maria lashed out with her limbs
trying to shake herself free from the
fishermen who were holding her down on
the deck she threw her gaze sideways and
saw an enormous net lifting a school of
fish out of the water there were
hundreds of them all thrashing and
slapping against one another and there
poking out of the bottom of the net was
a single tentacle dread filled her
stomach but her body gave out on her and
she fell unconscious all right we run it
one more time Dr Matthew sat at the
laptop and watched the grainy CCTV
footage for what felt like the H 100th
time it was footage from a fishing
vessel captured off the coast of Sagal
the first 30 seconds of the clip just
showed the view from the front of the
boat waves splashing here and there but
mostly Darkness then all of a sudden
there were two shapes moving through the
water one was a terrified woman
desperately swimming towards the surface
the other shape was harder to pin down
when Matthews had first watched the
video she'd seen a colossal sea creature
ring beneath the surface but each time
that she'd watched it since the creature
seemed to get a bit smaller and lose
some of its staying perhaps the shock of
what she was seeing had just been
wearing off regardless it was time to do
the mandatory checks before the latest
SCP was brought into the facility Dr
Matthews walked through the corridors of
the containment facility and came to the
large double doors that led into the
main hanger it had been hard to find a
facility large enough to contain this
SCP they knew it was capable of reaching
enormous sizes so they had to construct
an aquarium big enough to house it at
its maximum size Dr Matthew started
walking across the walkway it hung
suspended over the reinforced aquarium
and would be strictly off limits once
the SCP had been moved into the facility
it was far too easy for the squid to
Simply grab a member of staff and pull
them beneath the water she was heading
towards the control panel at the other
side the tank was 150 M cubed and so
walking the length of it took her well
over a minute this was by far the
biggest containment she'd ever been
involved with in terms of scale as well
as severity the logistics in trying to
organize the containment of this squid
had run into the millions of dollars and
were still going up every day it had
taken her and her research team a while
to convince the board that this SCP
posts a significant enough threat to
Warrant the investment she needed to
make sure not to screw it up guards
stood all around the perimeter of the
tank holding b74 Harpoon guns with
electrified discharge shafts looking
down into the water Dr Matthews could
see the 15 depth charges all hanging at
various Heights throughout the tank each
of these depth charges were wirelessly
connected to a computer that monitored
the Integrity of the glass all around
the tank if the SCP were to make even
the slightest crack in the glass all 15
depth charges were to be set off
simultaneously she hoped that was enough
to kill it God help her if it wasn't it
would keep one entity here for study but
she had reason to believe that there
were more of them all over the world and
so preparations were in place to arm a
team that could scour the oceans and
eliminate any others that were found
today was the day SCP 252 the humbled
squid was about to arrive the shipping
container was lifted by a crane and
carried to the right spot somewhere
inside it was a large sealed tank of
water holding an instance of SCP 252
there would dro the shipping container
into the reinforced aquarium and let it
sink all the way to the bottom before
detonating remote charges on its doors
and on the sealed tank inside allowing
SCP 252 to escape and fill its new
enclosure Dr Matthews stood with her
hand shaking over the button it was now
or never taking a deep breath she
pressed it down firmly and watched on
the security camera monitor as several
puffs of bubbles Rose from the container
and the doors swung open none of them
could see inside the container they just
had to wait then all of a sudden a small
shape darted out it was Tiny no more
than a meter in length what had happened
to the reports that this thing was 75 M
across Dr Matthews looked around at her
co-workers in shock she didn't expect to
see a monster to unfurl itself out of
the container and grow larger and larger
but all that had emerged Ed was a tiny
little black squid but none of her
colleagues looked back at her all of
them were staring wide-eyed at the
security feed Matthews glanced back and
saw that the little squid was flashing
various colors as it swam around just
like the CCTV footage that she had been
studying for the prior few weeks a
scream filled the room and was quickly
answered with another as her fellow
researchers ran away from what they were
seeing terrified by the shapes on the
screen Matthews just looked back and
forth in confusion the the Colossal sea
monster that had been reported to her
wasn't there there was just a tiny squid
flashing various colors what were all of
them so afraid of and now would she
break it to her boss that she'd spent
millions of dollars on a giant aquarium
loaded with depth charges for a squid
the size of a large dog two weeks later
she found herself attempting to do just
that standing in front of the
disciplinary panel Dr Matthews tried to
explain what had happened SCP 252 the
humbled squid is suspected to be the
origin of a lot of myths surrounding
giant squids and perhaps even the Kraken
itself when hunting all of the squids
pre attempts to flee by the most direct
path possible overcome with Terror at
what they were seeing the squid can
appear to be anywhere between 50 and 75
m in size with up to 200 appendages
growing from its mantle these appendages
can all take various forms often
depending on what the prey is most
afraid of for example a test subject who
is terrified of spiders will see the
hairy legs of a tarantula amongst the
tentacles but C is the important word
here because while SCP 252 appears to
take on its form the reality is that
these are all hallucinations brought on
by viewing the Squid's rapidly flashing
colors while hunting SCP 252 rapidly
Cycles its chromatophores which results
in powerful hallucinations all prey will
then immediately lay down their defenses
and try to flee as quickly as possible
leaving them open to being eaten by the
relatively small and weak real squid
however as Dr Matthews had discovered it
was possible to inoculate yourself
against these Effects by viewing the
grainy CCTV footage from the fishing
boat on repeat so many times in the
runup to SCP 22's arrival Dr Matthews
had built up a kind of immunity allowing
her to see the SCP as it actually was
even though her colleagues ran away in
Terror one fun fact Dr Matthew said is
that the prey will attempt to
rationalize the scp's side
even what it is in a confined space
that's impossibly small so if you were
taking a bath with the squid you would
somehow believe that the squid was both
75 M large and fully submerged in the
tub in your guest bathroom funny isn't
it none of the disciplinary board
members had a word they all stared at
her in bamus silence please don't fire
me now go check out SCP 354 the red pool
and a c snails fantasy SCP 1867 a
gentleman for more